And we're live,
ladies and gentlemen,
UFC fight companion podcast.
Well,
not necessarily.
You have to,
it's not UFC endorsed or supported.
And the opinions on this show are not those of the UFC.
Definitely.
Even though I'm UFC employee,
a proud u of c employee,
both of us,
both of us were watching the UFC fight pass or we're watching it on fight pass.
But we,
we might do this motherfucker for glory.
Okay.
We might do this motherfucker for the pack.
He,
I'll fight.
I'm here with Brendan Motherfucka Chalk.
What is,
uh,
and of course [inaudible] you can't say that I did too late.
Just happen.
Set it live.
Uh,
we are about to watch,
we're watching UFC fight pass.
We'll watch it on my computer so I can't pull up,
uh,
who is fighting.
But,
uh,
this is a lady fighter.
I lady,
there's so many fighters in the UFC now.
Even the employees of the UFC don't know who the fuck is,
who?
It's tough.
It's getting crazy.
There's 500 signed fighters that far surpasses the Dunbar's number of one 50.
That's tough.
Especially when it's international ICUs in Poland.
It's tough.
Man.
I remember back in the day when someone try to,
we'll try to get away with saying that they're a UFC fighter and you'd say,
yeah,
fuck you now.
Shit.
You'd have to do some research.
Yeah.
You can't just say,
fuck you.
You got to go.
He might be,
yeah,
my B.
And then you find out,
oh,
this dude.
Yeah,
he fought.
almost to six.
And I'm even like really good fighters.
Like how many people didn't know about Brendan Dash until he fought Benson?
Yeah.
I.
Dot.
Sanchez fucking budget.
I nightmare his name sounded familiar.
I was like fat.
Okay,
dude,
that guy's legit big in Denver.
He's big.
He's fucking good.
Oh,
that's your boy crush.
Calderwood and morose.
It's,
is that her name?
Moros how do you,
I don't know how to say it.
There's a lot of fighters from other countries now to man's,
one of the cool things that we're seeing.
Jamie,
give us a little volume so we can hear this too so we could hear the fights.
No one's told us to not do that.
So let's just keep doing that.
And I've got to take this fucking goofy,
a lava lamp town.
I can't see shit.
It's a big ass lava lamp.
So on this thing
still flows.
Insulation,
boom,
boom.
We're back.
It's hard.
You doing the commentating on this.
It doesn't sound like hardy if a play by play guy,
but I didn't hear him earlier.
Did you hear him?
I haven't heard him,
Jamie.
We lost it.
What happened?
What the fuck happened to on flight path?
I don't know.
MMM,
we're fucked.
Hmm.
Let me try us again.
Well,
um,
take this off because otherwise
take this off of my desktop can be what are,
what are people seeing right now?
Just us.
Okay.
Damn,
look at that picture.
Sucks.
Gary Anderson Silva.
I know that was one of the greatest knockouts of all time.
He could say no when he missed.
Yeah.
Not,
not because it was like most of the price set up.
It was just crazy.
Like as far as like the result of a knockout,
like the jolted sends through your body.
Wouldn't Weidman connected on Anderson?
It was like one of the greatest moments,
like not great.
Like,
I'm happy,
interesting got knocked out or none of that.
Just like the burst of what the fuck is more is doing.
Langland buster Douglas knocked out Tyson but crazier because he came out of
nowhere like Buster Douglas whooping that ass.
Buster Douglas was a hit true that long.
The handbooks through.
Wow.
He was hitting him with that.
That Larry Holmes style jabbing the hook behind it.
That was buster Douglas,
his finest moment.
I just saw that fight within the last six months and God damn,
even though buster,
buster Douglas looked amazing,
he looked flawless.
He was on fire,
but even,
and Tyson didn't train for it or whatever,
but if you look at Tyson,
even though he didn't train,
he looked good.
He looked good in that fight.
All his head movement was that he was still on big shot.
He was really trying to knock out buster Douglas with everything he had.
He was throwing a great shit.
Any did drop them in the eighth round,
dropped him.
Did you hear what Tyson speaking before that?
He was saying how he was just doing work on those Tokyo.
Is that right?
He was just doing work on some Asian lady.
He talked about doing more hours more than your mind.
Tyson.
He probably never took time off.
All right,
here we go.
Perfect timing.
We're back.
Fipass how dare you kicked me off like that.
It looks like an Atari game for you fucking guys.
How dare you?
How dare you.
I wonder how many half Mike Tyson kids are are in Japan,
right?
70 can we got Joanne Calderwood and Mirin and morose.
Here we go.
We're going to hear it.
Professional record.
Damn.
That bitch looks mean.
Five in no respect.
Five foot tall.
Oh no,
that's fine.
And I say bitch,
with all due respect,
I'm more kind of kicked off to holding an undefeated professional.
But Damn,
Scotland does not play games.
I've met this chick is tough as fuck.
She is good.
Joanne's back to whoop that ass.
She,
she does look like he's paralyzed,
right?
They're terrified.
Terrified.
That's the Carla Esparza a fact,
right?
It's not real.
I don't know.
Carla just does this and then she goes out there and with that,
not that last night,
but you not that last fight.
The last fight.
She was just,
the striking was so cool,
man.
Think that's true.
I think that chick is going to make what?
Was there any Joanna?
I think be right.
There she is.
She's the Ronda Rousey at one 15 we better striking.
She's gonna make everybody look like Carla.
She's terrible.
Look like Corey.
$100 they're going to look lost.
It's going to be able to take her down shit out of me to be able to take her
down.
If Carla can't take her down.
Most fighters in that division are not going to be able to take her down.
Well,
did you see her fight with Amanda Nunez
who's a very close fight in a lot of people actually thought that Nunez won the
fight.
I think it was Nunez,
right?
Was it Nunez?
I'm wrong.
Then she's a beast.
Oh Dude.
She's fucking,
she's wind pig.
She looked like that rafter.
She is intense.
I would Google her,
but I don't know how to say her name on Google either.
I can't even spell it if you gave me $1 million right now.
I'm going to try you on,
man.
Joanne got good striking.
She throws it some power.
I just tried Jay y,
z.
You want to Jay y,Z and let's see if they figure it out.
Dude,
isn't it weird?
I can't do this while I'm not a,
I'm a girls fight like dudes and I'm still not used to it.
How long did we think that girls can throw punches?
We just,
we believe that as a,
as a,
as a society.
Girls can't throw punches,
but then you look at Kathleen,
Kathleen Long.
Holy Shit.
Have you seen her?
Have you seen her highlight reel?
No.
She is the best American female kick and the eighties and nineties Holy Shit.
Old School when old youtube,
youtube search.
Kathy long highlight reel.
Who've seen Holly Holm.
You Seen Holly Holmes.
Do you know what all that can stand down for a moment.
Have you guys seen and mother fucking Wolf?
No.
What's the can,
we should stop watching this fight immediately and watch how Ann Wolfe used said
knock chicks.
Beautycon armbar wow.
Wow.
Armbar damn.
That was beautiful.
Cranium Ukrainian.
She was a huge underdog man.
That was beautiful.
Huge underdog.
I got to see how that was all set up.
We were talking about don't show the replay for sure.
We were talking about just girls will Kathy long.
No,
we were just talking about Ann Wolfe.
She pulled the car.
Wow,
that's pretty bad at join his haircut.
Look at this nice cause roll guard right into an arm bar that she just can't get
out of that.
That's what's crazy.
Control their legs.
Yeah.
Great controls like curls.
Look at those leg curls.
Damn Shit.
That is legit.
You know Eddie,
there's still people that say that you shouldn't cross your feet and I don't,
I don't agree with that.
It crossing your feet with the arm bar thing.
That's like people are pretending.
Some people pretend it's just like crossing the feet when you have someone's
back.
Well it all depends if the guys on their back and you're in spider web,
if they're on their back,
yeah,
you cross your feet all the time.
But if they're on top of you,
it all
depends on what's going on.
The angle.
I mean what,
what's going on with the arm?
Exactly.
And what's going on with the locking of the shoulder?
What angle?
Where is she,
uh,
put uh,
putting all her weight.
Watch this.
This is Ann Wolf.
She's going Americans.
He's a black check.
Oh,
check this.
Cause that American chicken.
Wait for some trauma.
Wait,
wait for some shit.
That's gonna Change Your feeling about what would happen if a chick punched you.
You just got to see this fucking chaos.
I think you'd be surprised.
Oh,
it hold up books.
This.
Oh Dude.
Are you fucking shitting me?
Are you fucking shitting me to Tyson dude,
she lifted her in the air.
Those ridiculous flying God.
That girl like literally went flying and wolf can bang and she changed.
She trains James Kirkland.
Who's a high level guy.
The Guy who your corner.
Yeah,
I see.
She's in a tense corner.
Let's see what she says.
Okay.
That's it.
Choose you too.
I want to make a champion.
I bet she does.
Great speech.
What powerful.
Dan Hardee liked Dan Hardee.
Men love that.
Great Guy.
The best.
He's good on the mic too.
He's very good.
He's very smart.
Her walk out of here just says fight night.
Just fuck it.
Fight night.
Does that Reebok,
I don't know what that has to be a better,
it says Reebok.
They're fighting has to be something bad.
Is that what they're calling it?
I hope not.
That better not be what they want people to buy.
I'm not wearing that.
I'm gonna fucking throwing a big brown on the back.
Maybe it's,
Oh you know what it probably is.
It's probably what they're wearing on fight night.
Like that's why.
Does that make sense?
I should probably ask somebody since I worked for hold on.
Oh that's beautiful.
Look at the control she has with her hands.
Boom.
No capitalization is small gap before the closure.
She didn't capitalize on that was a warm up and extend that for sure.
Don't stand up and extend the offer but she,
she hung out in there.
We should have squashed her.
Yeah,
she hung out in there when there was this one brief moment.
Was she going to pull the arm out?
Yeah.
Shit.
Damn.
How do you say join his last name?
Jared Dick again.
Jen jet check.
Shit like the laughing.
Well,
they know that that's where the money's at and that isn't that crazy.
Fuck you bitch.
Six.
Damn.
She powerful collared white shirt.
Beautiful.
I think we've come champ.
They should have a stylus where you right away.
You can't dress like an asshole anymore.
I put,
what about Roy Nelson?
If Roy Nelson became champ and decided to see Ya.
See,
no
one else would be sorry.
You're so wrong for women's MMA.
They should be allowed to pull hair and that'd be part of the game.
It's too much,
man.
So dark.
It's too much cool.
Not Cool at all.
Those girls.
Can you imagine the technique horrible too.
That'd be all of these different chokes you could do with the hair.
That's good.
Did I hear you man,
but this bugs me.
This,
this here's you inject,
check taken out of spar.
That too.
She's so lethal on the feet.
That's some real legit six time world more Thai champion right there.
Right?
Get that beautiful.
This is a goddamn firing gallery.
It's like she was just having like sparring practice with like pads that don't
hit back.
Do you know?
This was like,
it's like she was like,
she was hitting the Mitts with some light defense work,
right?
God Damn.
She's good to the technique that you see there.
That data is as clean as it gets when it comes to striking in MMA.
She got no pen.
That's a scary girlfriend I have right there.
She can fuck you up if you're not on your shin.
You're kind of drunk.
I shoot man.
I'll tell you what though.
No girlfriend.
Mine's walking out of the house.
You guys were in a real fight.
She was your girlfriend.
I would snap her downtown.
Now you would.
You'd fuck her up but kind of drunk.
You're in your underwear.
That's the thing though.
I think of girl like that needs a boyfriend like him.
She,
she needs a giant gorilla that she can't just kicking ass.
Multibillionaire dude is like a little old man that she beats up.
Shelly rides him.
Fucking little man.
Keep your life.
I keep your life at least to have her beat her up.
Beat him up,
dude.
A woman like that,
like you'd done.
That takes a lot of man.
You need an Alpha male.
The complete opposite.
Oh,
copped cro.
Cop would work.
She's not hot enough for cro cop.
Let's be honest.
Well,
how dare you.
I dare you.
I think she's,
I'm sorry.
She,
yes,
she's beautiful for cro cop though.
This mother fucker runs Croatia.
Can you imagine?
Imagine the damage he's doing.
Jesus Christ.
He's married.
He's got a family for that though.
I've tried and Denny was single.
Google this woman's name.
I've never had a harder time.
Google a woman's name.
I know termites are ticket checker.
I basically know how to say it,
but to spell it,
I really need to learn how to spell it.
It's,
it's preposterous that they require that of,
you know,
I think,
yeah,
I know,
man.
I'm trying to figure it out.
Click on it and see what's,
what was her last fight?
Go to her Wikipedia.
Besides Carla Esparza.
I want to say it was Nunez,
but I'm doing this totally off a memory and I might
get all
God,
that's,
it was,
it was Claude.
You get Dahlia.
Okay.
My account,
my apologies.
[inaudible] names are tough because in man and Nunez I think is a one 35.
Yeah,
she is.
She is.
Can we see,
uh,
the caffeine long add a highlight reel on that?
Is that possible?
[inaudible] fight.
That was a really fucking close fight.
A really close fight.
Pundits matchups man styles champ for awhile.
Well that's tricking.
Claude is very good dude.
Yeah,
she's very good.
I mean that was a really good fight between those two.
Um,
I'm not,
I think there's a lot of action in this division.
I think.
I really think that Joanna,
Joanna,
that's what he's saying is above and beyond the rest of them when it comes to
striking.
But there's some really good grapplers and that division and if they get ahold
of her,
who the fuck knows?
It's very,
very exciting.
That means it's true.
Every fighter is going to be taught.
It's true.
No one's going to take her down easily.
But a Stryker with really good wrestling might be able to pull it off.
The problem with Carla was the gap in the striking was so goddamn and norm and
the length,
the reach was troubling.
It's just an enormous gap and the striking like did get inside and she got deep
and that's beyond the striking.
Yup.
She couldn't finish it.
It's true.
She could gotten tagged before that though.
She definitely did.
She could have been diminished by that.
There's a lot of possibilities there.
If you saw the two of them,
I would have to go back and watch it again.
Um,
but if you,
if you watch anytime you see someone get tagged,
you know there's a possibility that they're functioning in a diminished
capacity.
Right?
Hell yeah.
That's what people need from round five
Jujitsu guy to fucking to stripe white belt.
I think he went back mount just and I had no idea.
I had no idea what was going on.
Yeah.
I thought I was fine.
And just weird when you think about how good you are on his hands are,
she could have easily clip Carla coming in and shirt and then your,
your,
your memory.
You know,
you're more skills or slow you,
you think you're moving at a good pace.
You're really not.
It's just the distance is,
there's a haze that distance you.
You seem like you're all right.
You're really not.
Everything's slow trouble man.
God Damn,
you just have some killer focus,
not days.
Ooh,
let me be a fighter.
Huh?
God Damn Dude.
Did you see the Jamie Varner Shit?
The interviews a Jamie Varner has been doing lately.
What's he talking about?
Very interesting.
He's talking about how he thinks fighter should spar way less than they do.
He's like,
what you need to be doing.
It's working on drills,
hidden pads,
working out on strength and conditioning,
you know,
do your wrestling and Hugh Jitsu.
But he's like hardcore sparring should be done once a week at most and not,
and only when you're preparing for a fight.
I agree 100%.
He said maybe you could even stretch it out to even more than once a week,
like once every two weeks.
He's like,
what's really important is that you,
you take care of your brain and he makes sure you don't spar with bigger guys.
He was saying that he,
he made mistakes by sparring with,
um,
uh,
he's sparring with,
um,
who was it?
Uh,
who's with me?
Bader.
I know he's part of the Beta.
I think he's sparred with Bazinsky who's a little bit large than them,
too big.
Um,
CB Dalloway he's larger than him too.
When you and painters,
big dude,
he's a big boy.
Big fic.
Motherfucker throws haymakers he's uh,
he's a hard puncher.
I agree 100% with Jamie.
Jamie [inaudible] a 155 or,
and he's fighting a guy that's literally fighting the division 50 pounds heavier
than him and he's sparring with that guy,
you know?
I mean,
that's pretty crazy.
Binders at two oh five,
you know,
that's,
that's bananas.
You think we'll ever see Bader striking like Conor McGregor?
Well,
he,
you know what I mean by that is by just utilizing every possible strike,
he would have to change a lot about the way he moves.
You know,
I think Beta has gotten a lot better and his striking like,
no doubt.
Like the Phage,
I'll fight to perfect example of that.
Like Fazio is a legit striker.
If you watched his fight with King Mo and strike for us.
You see what kind of striking Fazio has when he's on point.
Even later Glover's he showed you to strike and he clipped him with a right
hand.
Yes he did.
He did clovers a monster.
He heard him before he got caught when he was trying to close the deal.
Um,
that's totally true.
He's really good.
He's getting much better too.
He works hard.
You can totally tell.
See that.
Uh,
there's a video going around like a highlight of the capillary MMA.
Have you seen this?
No.
They're doing spinning kicks and Shit Dude.
I don't know if it's fake.
It looks real.
It's some vocabulary is just like wheel kicks,
Super Athletic Guys Against Cup of water guys and that's what they're throwing.
They're just throwing massive double spinning wheel kicks that are doing all
that shit and Jujitsu.
They go on the ground and choke each other out.
When I was going to say about Brian Bader in that like we were saying,
do you think you'll ever have like a four snow is the way moves to something
wrong with the way like when think wrong?
See,
I don't think wrong is wrong.
I don't think it's in his wheel house.
I mean for kicking.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like you would not even wrong with the way he moves because obviously the way he
moves is effective,
but it's almost like his lower legs.
Like he keeps them close together when he's,
if you watch like a Machida or you watch like a branded fache like real strong
traditional karate type background,
which is the one that allows you to get away with everything.
Socratic type guy,
you know,
he throws a lot of wheel kicks.
You can throw everything.
That's what I'm talking because I can't like Pettis at once.
You would have to have a wider stance so it's not,
there's something wrong with it was something wrong.
If you wanted to throw all those kicks and all that other crazy shit.
He look at Anderson,
there's a wider stance.
If you look at taekwondo guys,
there's a wide stance going on.
I think that's the only way you get to throw those kicks.
Like with Moyie Thai,
you can stand way closer because it's Moitai you're throwing round kicks mostly
and occasionally tepes but when you want to go off that back leg with anything
where you're spinning,
you want to have a little bit more space.
And I think if he wanted to have like Conor McGregor style,
he would probably have to stand like Mcgregor.
If you see how McGregor standing,
it's very wide stamp.
Super.
What would you think a,
it's a good idea for every guy getting
into MMA to try to emulate,
uh,
some,
style like that.
Everyone,
the Christ.
How works though,
man,
if you get good at it,
that it's when it's hard to hit a guy.
Like if you ever watch a good point fighter fight like Raymond Daniels,
we've Seen Raymond Daniels fight and glory.
Yes.
Only the super high level guys have been able to get past that.
Like the guys like Niki hold skin.
He's,
he's the guy who gets passage,
a monster talking about wonder boy Joseph.
He's tough to hit man.
Yeah,
the UFC,
he's a phenomenal points.
Joseph [inaudible],
he's a perfect example of a guy gets passed Raymond Daniels and he's the champ
cause he just kicked his legs out from under him.
He just used traditional solid Moyie Thai hands up kickboxing style block
through a lot of fucking leg kicks.
Took him out and then took them out with a head kick.
But everybody else when Daniel's fights ago can't deal with that kind of hopping
in and out.
Shit.
It's lethal.
It's legal.
So he had to have a guy like Conor McGregor style or like a guide,
like a Leonardo or thatch and couch rose was wild kicks.
If Bader wanted to do that,
he would definitely have to widen it stance.
I don't think Beta is ever going to do that.
I also think the style you're describing is,
is in those guys.
Thatch,
Connor Machida,
they're phenomenal athletes.
Phenomenal.
And that might not be,
you don't think of Bain is a phenomenal athlete compared to Machida.
I don't think he's as skilled in karate or in stand up as Machida is,
I mean Machida's a sly professional high level fighter and when they fought
explosive.
Yeah.
Well the Cheetahs Jim Maci she is pretty special.
He's pretty special.
That gave special all those guys.
Sometimes I think certain styles aren't in guy's wheels.
Does that make sense?
Like Bob Sapp isn't going to fucking adapt to the taekwondo ever.
It's true.
Guys are made for it.
Too much mass there.
Right.
Well is a massive food and but he could do it cause phaseout can do those kind
of kicks page.
How could throw wheeled care cause he's a thick fucking dude to Melvin man who
have,
who's thicker than that fucking guy when it was explosive and athletic.
Once you know a Melvin you don't see throw wheelchair because either you assume
mostly with straight,
more tall,
straight Moyie Thai leg kicks like a motherfucker who said what the fuck is
different man,
I just don't like throwing them.
That's true.
I agree.
Some guys don't because cause you got it cause they're no good at them because I
don't practice them at all.
I'm a victim of that.
I'm just saying certain guys,
like a guy like Bader who comes from a wrestling background,
the chances of him adapt and that's not good and you have to have the athletic
ability to pick it up.
Well,
I don't think Conor came from that background entirely.
You know?
I think he's kind of picked that kicking style up more.
I think it started more as a boxer and boxer.
Yeah,
but he also taekwondo karate,
right.
He spends a lot of time with a homie in Iceland one day.
Gunnar Nelson Machida,
wicked,
wicked.
She is single handedly everything.
Great.
Brought back karate.
I mean you can't say shit about karate.
Look at my,
you can't say shit about karate.
You can't say shit man.
This is what we're going to have a couple of weeks.
The UFC who comes out and it's stolen all them crazy.
Cowboy Caesar,
Caesar Mouton.
It has though.
Cesar Mouton not going out.
That's his background.
He's really fun to start off with that.
He's just based super,
super good guy.
There's a lot of guys who've training cup of wire who've done the UFC,
I'm sure,
but who actually go out there and stand like those capillaries move through
that.
We'll throw a guy off.
What do you guys think about,
um,
about uh,
Daniel Cormier and Bader?
I would have to go with Cormier.
That's going to be a great fight,
man.
I friction really good.
I love data.
I love DC.
DC helps me out a lot.
They're both really good dude.
Good for the sport man.
Way of describing the great for the sport.
Dcs from New Orleans.
It's in his hometown.
Dude.
You look at dcs track record.
There's not too many dudes beating him.
There's one guy on this earth who can beat him.
It's Jon Jones.
I don't think he will ever beat John Jones.
No.
How could it's John?
John Discuss what the fuck it's posturing.
We're watching this man.
I don't think we ever get someone as good as John Jones.
I just don't bother brighter.
He's something special.
Oh,
and guess what?
Now he's training full time,
moved to Albuquerque.
Have you seen his Instagram?
Because Instagram is Bali house in Albuquerque.
That means there's no distractions.
He's trading full time.
Oh,
he thought he was good before.
Enjoy that.
Beautiful.
Um,
you know,
I'd say the same thing about Anthony Johnson.
He,
yeah,
you can.
Yeah,
Antioch,
we've Seen Anthony Lewis though.
We've seen Bruce,
we've seen issues in Anthony's game.
We've never seen an issue in Jon Jones game ever.
That's true.
Well,
you know what,
we have that one aspect of Andrew Johnson's game that you can't neglect when you
talk about him.
That's the fucking extreme weight cut.
And it used to make sure who made the most extreme way cut in the sport.
Have we used to all see him walking around and hotels in between fights and he
would be,
he fucking normous who'd be like 220230240 two I saw him at two 40.
Oh my God.
And then he would fight at one 70.
Why?
Why the fuck didn't so and sit them down like you're cutting 80 pounds.
Why don't we relax,
homey?
Why don't you pick somewhere else?
What are you doing?
What's the thought process that he likes?
Being a bully is how it is,
man.
I think why the fuck else would,
I mean,
what are you doing?
Well,
you know this also here.
How about this?
Some guys think that they're not doing all they can do to be a champion and
less,
they cut as much weight as they can to get to a lower weight as they can.
They think it's a part of this is that they think it's a part of the discipline
of being a fighter that you have to make that weight and they look at it as a
badge of courage when he's,
they have to.
He's mess weight.
So many times someone was just be like,
Yo,
how about Weidman then?
What do you think about Wyman?
Wyman has a hard cut 2085 he makes it,
he makes it pretty pretty well.
He's obviously the most professional
because he's the champion,
right?
He always gets on weight,
even in the fuckers.
Never missed it though.
That's almost missed it or he didn't almost miss it,
but he had a really hard time with it.
In the fight with the fuck's his name?
An Italian boxer.
Oh,
of Philippi?
No,
no,
no.
I suck.
Uraba or us the car.
Remember that?
Legionaries Alessio Succar he took that fight.
I think that was on like a real short notice to pat fight in the Maya
[inaudible] super short notice.
That's what it was.
Me and Maya fight and it's on TV.
That was eight days.
Yeah.
That's different.
That was it.
That wasn't the legionaries fighty crushed him,
right?
Yeah.
Crushed.
Maya went to decisions short notice and it was a stand up fight.
Most of the time that was,
that was when Ray Longo was yelling at his corner.
I saw what you've got through at the fucking way and if you can lose that kind
of way can you can get through this.
Just give him the pep talk during the fight.
Yeah.
How great is Ray Longo?
The thing with the Maci er with a Weidman though is there's,
again,
there's no holes in his game.
It's Anthony Johnson.
We've seen him cut weight and there's holes in his game.
Has Tried Min that we haven't seen you yet.
Man.
Mother fuckers and animal.
He's an animal.
He's a special type of long island animal that you never want to have a fight
with at a bar.
How about his boy?
I Quinta.
It's crazy.
I love it.
I love that.
Was there to interview him?
Man would love that.
When he was like,
fuck you mean fuck you.
I loved it.
He didn't get in trouble for that.
Right?
I don't know.
Now that should give him a bonus.
I agree.
I will.
Thousand dollars wanted to get,
if I was there,
I wanted to climb through the fucking screen and interview them.
I wanted to,
I wanted to like,
like when he was hitting fact saying fuck you.
first of all he wasn't his fault.
You know who the fighter and he's not the judge.
He went on and gave,
he gave it his all.
Jon.
Anik was like,
okay,
it looks like we've got some curse words here.
Yeah,
just shut.
It's like,
all right,
take care.
All right.
I don't even ask him to stay.
I would have congratulated him on I really tough fight.
It was a great five and just score the fight.
I thought Mazda,
I'll probably edged him.
Oh,
I disagree.
Really know.
I had al winning two and three I think.
I thought the first round was pretty dominant from Moscow,
from dominant from Hungary and I think the the other two rounds I find Mosfet al
did just enough.
Who?
I disagree.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't think it was nearly as dominant as the first round.
I would have to go.
I would like to go over it again.
Watch it with you.
Let's do that.
Let's go do it.
We'll watch it after the fight.
That'd be cool.
Would you say a metal doll is a ten eight first round?
I could see it being a draw.
If you want to go that route.
I can see a draw.
If you give it ten eight that first one I think that definitely should be a
wider disparity in scoring.
If that is a ten nine but then the less the last two rounds were also ten nine.
I agree.
Fight demonstrates it.
Right.
That fight demonstrates the difference between the first round,
the domination that Mosfet all showed that first round and then the really
debatable second and third round.
Mosler adult kindness.
It's coasted though,
especially the round.
And the second
I thought he was losing it,
man.
Kinda did.
And he hasn't.
Well you know,
who knows.
This is the thing dude.
You know what?
As much as I knew what you mean,
you never know what the fuck's going on with these guys when they get into,
he could have been clipped.
He could've been clipped in the second round.
We don't know when he was coasting cause he just wasn't there.
Well it could have been that he was hurt in training.
He could have been oh,
big huge knee.
Oh Sham.
Nice central.
We don't,
we haven't mentioned this fight once,
now.
Route once or rude.
Let me,
uh,
let me find out what fight.
This is
where the worst commentators ever.
The main,
main co main event is the bomb.
Um,
yeah.
Especially the co main event.
That's the best fight on the card.
Which one's that?
That's min awall verse the the Polish cat.
The Polish cad is beaten a lot of UFC guys and a lot of people don't know.
Yes.
Um,
he beat Houston.
Alexandra,
you put up the card,
like the full card so we could see what the whole main card is.
This is a,
we're right now we're watching Palo Powell block and Sheldon Wescott.
It looks like a good fucking fight so far,
but we were talking about all kinds of other shit.
First of all,
I got to go back to this Roy Nelson thing and strongly disagree that he gets a
full style bro.
Get a stylist and the rest of these guys proper SEO look like assholes.
He looks like Royal Goddamn Nelson.
He's a fabulous human being and not everybody has to be metro.
Not Everybody.
I'm just saying a beautiful UNC can hire me as a stylist.
The first thing I'll do is go to Joanna,
the 150 pound champ.
I'm like,
yeah,
that,
that business a button up your wind.
Let's get rid of that.
Let's ditch that.
You know,
I'm saying
that's hilarious Roy.
No more tee shirts.
Belize.
Genzler would be Roy.
I love Roy.
God love her too,
man.
He's alive.
God loved the what's next for him?
Um,
that's a good question.
Last over.
The more unique characters we have,
the better,
you know,
that's fine.
He can dress nice and be a character.
You don't have to look like fucking,
they like they just booked a fight for him.
God dammit.
You see that documentary?
The chic yet the chic?
Yeah,
the iron sheik documentary.
No,
this documentary.
Good.
I love me.
So I was into the WWE.
I was in the WWE just watch culture high by the way.
It's pretty good.
Dope.
If I could,
I would do it,
but I would,
I mean I was like,
damn,
I'm fro,
we'd iron sheik story.
Did the iron sheik story is fucking amazing.
You know,
he was,
he was an Iranian national champion wrestler.
Jet Wrestle ended up being a body guard for the Shah,
the Shah.
I love the wrestlers and the top Iranian wrestlers and the May,
his main body guard dude,
I forget his name,
but he was the best Iranian wrestle ever and he was his main body guard.
The Shah,
that dude ended up committing suicide.
So everyone thought,
oh shit,
he got killed.
So the iron sheik,
he was one of the bodyguards.
He decided to bolt
bolted the Minnesota.
I'll
scan yet,
but he was the second best wrestler and I,
and I ran and he started teaching,
um,
the Olympic wrestling team,
number one,
he was really good.
Um,
and you,
you know,
it's crazy.
You know why he,
he wasn't even like a,
you know,
how his character is the iron sheik with that would look,
what did they call those head pieces,
what are they call it or whatever.
That wasn't a turban.
And he was
totally western.
I ran,
was totally Westernized.
He had nothing to do with any of that.
None of those guys are like that.
He was like,
he was arrested,
was an athlete he did where he was a regular dude.
He didn't,
he wasn't like that.
But once he slowly started getting into pro wrestling in Minnesota,
he would coach like the college team live.
And there were national champions five years in a row.
He was an amazing restaurant at University of Minnesota.
Yes.
Oh,
somewhere in Minnesota and,
and for the Olympic team.
And he was,
he was the man in wrestling and he started getting into pro wrestling,
not as iron sheet,
just as an American,
a Limpic,
a coach type.
He was an American,
but he was really an Iranian so that someone told him,
his wife told me,
he goes,
you should,
his wife suggested that he,
he,
he uses that debt because,
uh,
because she likes money.
Well,
we were in that Iran.
Exactly right.
Wrestling's great.
Why don't we make some fucking money?
And you get a personality at that time.
At that time,
yeah.
Wrestlers are death row.
That's when we were at,
we were about to go to war with Iran back then and everybody,
you know,
the whole [inaudible] thing.
So she,
they took advantage of that.
They jumped on that.
How crazy is that to suit him though?
In America?
He loved it.
He loved,
he loved being the heel.
Really.
He started blowing up in Minnesota.
Then Vince Mcmahon heard about this.
The reason why he ended up being,
listen,
the reason why I ended up being,
you know,
getting the championship belt,
he'd be Bob Backlund.
But the way that Shit's decided,
they talk about this and the,
and uh,
I mean openly about how these Bob Backlund was the American WWF champion and
they want to hell again dude.
What
they wanted to bring in Hulk Ho Kogan how are we going to make him a champion?
Vince man,
big man goes,
well,
he can't beat the American champion.
We need a villain to come in to beat Bob Backlund.
So then Hulk Hogan saves the day.
We have a villain champion for like a year or two and then I'll say,
and then it blows up.
So they needed the perfect villain.
They fucking found it.
They find I found iron sheik perfect time.
The crazy thing about iron sheik is he wouldn't lose because in reality he knew
he could beat everybody here.
Something real restless.
Yes,
exactly.
So they're like Brock,
they all respect even hulk Hogan,
they all,
they all talk about this in the documentary.
The reason why the iron sheik was the only one that would beat him was hulk
Hogan because he was the best wrestler.
He
gets fucking hole and they all know it.
They all knew it.
So he took,
and Hulk Hogan says this,
you know,
it says iron.
She could beat it.
He could beat anybody in any room for real.
So for him to lay down for me and let me and pass the torch to me,
that created Hulkamania,
him passing the torch.
I actually had a
real
gentlemen,
you're going to see this and have you seen it?
It's the best.
So much sadness and that that wouldn't have been no whole combined glorious
smell areas still looks good.
I watched it a few seconds of what I getting a steak suck.
I be still yoked
dude.
Oklahoma called with the arms were huge.
Still fucking Yo yo grounds here.
It's like a weird,
that's a weird love triangle with something someone got betrayed and that weird
love to put on the line like his best friend's girl or something like that.
They have some weird thing in the middle.
He's like,
hold on.
Nick's calling,
why he's getting his dick sucked checked his bone.
It's the hoaxed or man,
I'm not mad at him at all,
Larry.
No one gave a shit,
right?
That a sex tape.
I think if I think [inaudible] fans were like sad,
how dare you hope that if you found out that hooked did that on purpose,
I'd be a bigger fan on.
They talk about AI or shaping a massive coke head,
like he got busted with hacksaw dug in and the car they got pulled over and had
a bunch of coke and weed on him.
He met the nights.
Those two partied hard.
Iron Sheik is a mad party or did you see that ad for steeping meal check?
Good.
That's a fucking five big,
big fan of Steve Bay.
Man.
After that fight with junior dos Santos,
I was like,
this guy,
he's still getting better.
He's still getting better.
He's fucking really good and still getting better.
You smiling.
Heavy waits,
son of a bitch.
Competitive motherfucker.
I think,
don't get me wrong,
Steve Bay's a fucking monster.
He's a monster.
I think that fight was more of Dos Santos,
the Cain Velasquez fights took its toll on him.
A lot of people believe that that's a little bit of speculation.
Surgery every other week.
And he uh,
he's,
he's definitely beat up.
I've heard that for that speculation.
He boy,
no girls fighting again.
It's truth.
Wow.
Why are boy
well we both love him.
Your love,
all of us love him.
Fuck yeah.
You know it's level.
It's one of those,
it's hard to watch.
They'll do real legends like that breaks your heart going out like the Roy
Nelson fight was hard for me to watch.
That was a hot was the worst fight I've ever seen.
The words fight where it's like,
oh my God,
it was like a shotgun going off.
Yeah.
When he got chaos,
you know,
it was,
it was tough to watch.
I told you man,
when,
when little nog fought Anthony Johnson,
I was in the back warm and Pat Cummings up cause there's
corn pat for that fight and he was just so beat up,
his body was so beat up,
he couldn't hit myth.
He was just sitting down like we are now.
Wow.
Burt comes by and Albert goes,
fine.
The whole Europe,
no sweats.
Walks up fucking Christmas stair walks up,
goes out there,
gets fucking annihilated.
Or do you think that he's just had too many fights?
Yeah.
Too much training time.
Too much.
Too much,
too many wars in the gym.
Too many wars in the octagon.
Tom,
I won the best ever man.
Yeah.
So back to that Jamie Varner thing.
Jamie Varner was saying that,
um,
he believes he's having,
he's had about 30 concussions.
Dirty.
Yeah.
Or maybe more.
That's what is his doctor fight?
Estimated.
I don't know how his doctor estimated that they did MRI brain scan if they,
I dunno what they did,
but whatever it was,
his doctor urged him to retire and uh,
you know,
then he started talking about cognitive issues,
memory issues,
things along those lines.
Then he sees a cognitive therapist once a week to deal with them.
This guy's got Jujitsu,
man.
It's very good.
I can't name too many fighters should have retired rank where I'm like,
God damn,
that guy's sharp.
You're doing really well.
My man,
I can't name too many.
My Randy seems fine,
man.
When he talked to Randy,
Randy coture is very lucid.
He's fine.
And he had his last fight really late in life.
I think he was 48 his last fight.
It's true.
And what he started competing at what,
42 36 I believe it was his first UFC fight.
I was there.
That was in the home over here.
That was in,
who the fuck was my hair was lush.
It's fucking dope.
He got a rear naked choke and his first UFC,
Randy couture.
Um,
Randy coture.
I remember he took the Tony Halma.
Yeah.
He tried to,
to Tony Hama and he fought this other dude too that night that had real promise.
I forgot the gentleman's name.
Did he get his back?
He got his back as well.
Right.
Um,
I don't remember what he did to him.
He might've mounted him and grounded pounded him.
But the Tony Hama one was big,
right hand ducked under.
It.
Took him down.
Had is well with them towards a legend.
What Stud?
How about when Liotta kicked his tooth out and he's like,
you know what,
I'm done with this bullshit.
He's like enough and kicked it delays God damn movies
about to do some expandable series.
Spendable 67 yeah,
he's an animal.
I feel real bad that he in the UFC had that falling out was because of a son to
write poems.
He cornered his son or some shit like that.
Right.
Well I don't know if you can quantify stones right out,
but I think the thing that kicked it into overdrive,
I think there was a few issues over the years,
whether the thing that kicked it into overdrive was him doing that Bella tour
show.
Yeah,
that'll do it.
Yeah.
After they put him in the UFC hall of fame,
he signed up to do that Bella tour show and you know,
was asked to show,
you know,
man,
we all different opinions about these things.
You thought the show was good?
No,
no,
no.
Nothing.
I can wait.
I didn't watch it.
Honestly.
I mean different opinions about like whether or not he should have been able to
go in to some rival organization and pump up the organization.
So,
you know,
it's debatable.
It's tough.
He was a champion of one organization.
They,
he but you kind of do what you gotta do,
man.
If people offer you some money,
you know,
and you have an opportunity to give him a stipend after he's retired.
I got weird feelings on um,
on competitiveness and a MMA right now,
competition amongst organizations in MMA.
And my weird feeling is I didn't get,
I don't think it's necessary.
I don't think,
and I think it will be a lot less of this now that Scott Coker is over at Bella
[inaudible] a lot less.
Yeah,
he goes up.
I don't think so man.
All your crazy hostility.
It's not going to go,
I disagree because bell towards it can get bigger.
Yeah.
It's going to get picked up.
Cokers legit.
He is legit,
but I think the UFC likes him.
You know,
they worked with him when he was the owner strike force and it is possible.
That was then,
yeah,
it is.
It's all fun and games till till the bell tours.
A legit threat.
Have you watched bell lately?
Yeah,
I watched it last night.
You don't Miss One?
I don't miss a UFC.
You don't even know I'm UFC today.
I die.
I don't miss one dude.
The uh,
I enjoyed it.
Um,
Marcin held.
He's got some fucking nasty Jujitsu.
Jesus Christ.
How about your boy?
Did Joe Schilling,
how about Joe Schilling is good fight.
He thought he won the fight after it was over edge.
Blog.
Do like these you're going to eat.
We've got to remember.
Um,
Brooks,
he won the fight.
It was a very close fight.
Super close.
He'd think takedowns a tough,
yeah.
Shilling did more damage,
but the dude did get dominant position on him a bunch of times,
which shouldn't mean as much,
but it does oftentimes the way they scored it does.
When the guy's on top of you and sigh control for prolonged periods of time,
for whatever reason,
that's worth a lot.
Even if he doesn't hurt you.
It is,
but it probably shouldn't be.
We should probably figure out like what is what is actually it was one thing
where you're controlling a guy,
but if you're controlling guy and you're not getting any damage done,
what difference does that make?
Like is it,
is it 50% of controlling guy and doing damage that lasts than that?
Well,
you've got to quantify it.
The one positive thing I saw and Bella Tours when I'm homeboy Emanuel fought
who?
He just lost to the Henzel Gracie guy and Newton.
The Manual Newton.
Yeah,
and he just lost it.
I didn't see that fight.
I missed you watch that fight a manual took the guy down a ton and the guy was
so active off his back triangle armbars so active and they gave him the win
because he's just threatening nonstop.
Nonstop.
You know who does that?
Charles Olivera.
Yes.
Ooh,
you get that kid on is a nightmare on his back.
Feet and back.
He's scrambling on his back.
You know what cowboys?
Similar.
We don't see how boys very simply how boys God game is nasty.
That's what I'm interested in seeing.
This fight.
He badgering.
If cowboy could submit Habib.
He say good cove.
Milby days.
Good googly Mowgli.
That is a tough fucking fight.
Tough.
That's a tough fucking fight for both guys.
Speaking a tough fight.
I saw a fucking,
uh,
Machida yesterday.
Spar five rounds.
Like it was nothing.
Not Shit.
10 really that fights in two weeks to how's he look best I've ever seen it.
Do you do what you think about a professional?
What?
Yeah.
Fuck we has to be,
he doesn't have much time left man.
You know,
I mean you think he's 36,
37 years old.
There's athletic prime is probably,
you know right now is about maintaining the,
the super high level he's at right now.
But like biologically in this day and age without taking anything,
you're,
you're going to start to the dummy branch that,
that pretty significant diminish diminishment,
Tony man though there's,
there's no one more professional in him.
He's awesome.
Can you do a documentary on Liotta just called the professional.
The mother fuckers just,
he's a legit Marshall rs 365 days a year.
Yeah.
He's a super nice guy.
He's still drink urine.
Hey,
how dare you think how they bring that up?
No,
I think someone schooled him on that.
They're,
you can't be drinking piss and I'm,
I drink my piss a couple of times.
I tried it like a a month.
Did you really try to tried it a few times?
Tried it too.
After I saw Machita dude,
I was like,
shit,
I'm just going to heat this show.
Really it's not that big a deal.
You know?
Everybody makes it out.
That is a big deal.
It's your own piss.
I'd really,
I did it and it with a Dj on the radio and he almost threw up was hilarious.
Really stupid.
No name in San Francisco.
He didn't think,
I don't think he thought I was going to do it.
He was like,
Joe,
you drink this pice.
Well,
it's really stupid to do.
Don't do it folks,
but there is some thought that certain vitamins or antioxidants,
I forget the the rap.
I would never do it if I read about it today.
But when I did it back in the day,
I was a little bit more susceptible to the Internet.
Has schooled me on the reality of drinking Joe Piss run in the UFC.
I saw the Cheetah do and I started thinking piss man.
That's how it goes.
There's the way I look at it.
I,
I don't know shit about why um,
we can't just piss out of our asses.
Why do we need our dicks to,
uh,
get rid of liquid waste?
I mean,
that's a sign this is coming from
your peers is designed to clean that important.
You're re throw out multiple times a day cleaning bacteria so that it can't,
that you're pissed can't be filled with bacteria.
It's cleaner.
It's cleaning your dick out.
That's your body made cleaner for your Dick to keep it clean.
Shut.
When you shoot out sperm,
it's healthy and clean.
Dude,
you should be a scientist.
I straight up.
That's my guess.
That's my guide upside to this.
That's my gas at two out about 10 tickets in or that you don't think that makes
sense?
It does a little.
I guess
there has to be a special reason for pes are otherwise we just piss out of our
asses.
Every animal does it that way too.
But women don't ejaculate and they pee out of their vaginas too.
So that's some of that.
Throw a wrench into it.
No,
no,
no.
Cause everyone's born a woman.
Everyone's not born a woman.
Everyone's hatched a woman.
That's when you are a,
when you're an embryo,
every one's a woman.
That's why we all nipples.
Yeah.
Whatever the difference in the chromosomes are.
You know,
obviously I'm doing a shitty job with the biology here,
but you know,
we're x,
y.
That's what men are.
I've always said this,
snacks hits that.
Y gets established.
Testosterone kicks into gear,
dit,
and you become a boy.
But everything in the beginning,
every embryo,
whatever it is,
every now and then,
what starts out as a female to be obsessed with Dick size?
No.
When it comes to women to less than nothing.
Yeah,
it's there's,
there's a void.
There's nothing that,
it's nothing.
It's a whole,
it goes in and there's a void.
Have you heard of that lady valor then the navy seal?
What do you mean?
I'm just trying to and hold on.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just trying to figure out what you're saying.
You know,
God,
when a girl likes a guy guy's private parts,
there's actually a six,
seven,
eight,
eight inches of a thing that they have to,
you know,
for some reason they liked the way it looks,
I don't like.
But when it comes to,
when it comes to female genitalia,
we are obsessed with avoid.
There's nothing.
Not only is there no eight inches,
but it goes eight inches deep of nothingness.
So there's just a void that we have to,
I don't know.
We're obsessed with.
That doesn't make any sense.
Exactly.
It makes zero sense.
Not avoid anything that grabs your finger,
dude.
That's the outer edges.
No,
the inside cause your finger.
He squeezes.
It's like saying your mouth as a void.
It is.
It's a whole,
the vacuum bro.
Raiders,
stone biology.
Rent of all time.
Hold up.
Why the fuck that's a jockey.
Ravers Chris Kamozi.
Where's my boy?
Fucking,
oh,
that's right.
You didn't hear him?
Yeah,
he got hurt.
No fucking way,
man got hurt.
He got hurt a couple of days ago already fought.
Chuck writes a minimum,
like three second Kamozi gets a rematch on fucking Fox.
Good for him.
He's a Denver boy.
I like shit,
dude.
He brings it one day.
Boom.
Big Brown up in there.
Two Oh five one day.
Joseph.
I'm trying to figure out,
trying to figure out the rankings here.
Did you hear big brown mentioned two oh five yeah.
What do you weigh right now I'm about to 47 I've lost six pounds in a week.
How does it feel to lose six pounds?
Glorious.
Does it feel good?
I feel great.
You feel physically good?
Great.
What did you do?
Would you change just calories or the tallies?
I buy food.
I was doing it myself,
you know,
for like two or three months and you just can't do that man.
So I hired a and
do they prepare the meals for you and every drop him off every Sunday meals.
Water plan,
everything.
I checked in with them all the time.
So you easier that way,
right?
Wazer so do you help one of those body fat tasks and a body composition test?
Do they do that stuff too?
No.
No he can.
I just,
I don't want to drive out there to all that shit.
The good thing with those is those are numbers.
You know,
you get it down on paper.
You got to make sure that you're hydrated because those things,
the,
the equipment that they use,
unless they're dunking you,
it can,
it can be a little fuckery.
There's always like a plus or minus 3% on those things.
Right.
Those bod pods,
I think they say the calpers,
the little pinchy things like the least effective,
the most effective is the flotation.
This is a bad motherfucker.
Jimmy Manoa.
He is a bad model.
Only losses to Augusta to these aren't even doing MMA for like six years.
He's like,
he's like a straight off the street,
right?
Yes.
Got It.
Dan Athlete for sure.
It's a nasty striker dude.
Serious fucking power.
This Jan Dude's no punk man hit.
He's no guys.
And then Jimmy,
Jimmy,
you have to call in on.
Is His name?
[inaudible].
How do they see cousin goes here,
Colorado.
Call them fucking Jan.
All right.
Where's he from?
He's from Poland.
This is his hometown.
Colorado in Denver,
Colorado.
Recom Jan,
but it's probably young for sure.
He said he had,
yeah,
so Yans Houston Alexander,
he's be Soca Jew.
He beat you.
Remember that?
Uh,
what's his fucking name?
How relic Chiarella dude going yell.
Rally.
Yeah.
Well you ask Croatian beat him.
What happened to that dude?
That dude has potential,
right?
He had skills.
I think he's just think about him today.
Thank you.
Got Injured.
His standup was nasty.
He was a mean dude and he was really good.
I think a man who was the favorite.
I'm taking my boy Yan as we call them in Denver.
Strong words.
John Words for I know Colorado Kid.
What?
I guess this guy's just a Harrell out there in Poland is it might see my
feelings about this whole bellatore UFC thing is it doesn't have to be some
crazy fucking hatred between the organizations.
Everybody would benefit if everybody benefits.
I really believe that the sport of MMA still has room to grow.
And I think that a big organization that is alongside the UFC is not a bad thing
and it's a very good thing for the athletes.
It's a very,
it's great for the athletes spare for the athletes in the UFC.
It's very good for the athletes.
I think the UFC is obviously above and beyond in terms of like,
the talent is,
it's not even close,
but it's not a bad thing to have [inaudible] around.
I think they do a great job.
I enjoyed the shit out of the fights.
Yeah,
I like them in.
I don't miss them.
I enjoy the shit out of Joe Shellings fight.
That was a great Joe Schilling.
Does Gloria and Bella Tony's house fucking dope beast.
That dude is a star rate up savage.
He's a straight killer.
Super talented and a real good dude too.
Real good dude.
How many it was bell tour guys you think would come into the UFC and welcome
Cindy?
Well,
not many.
Um,
you know what man?
You really don't know until they get in there.
You don't know.
Eddie Alvarez.
What?
He fought Donald and Donald was on point just saying Donald was on point with
any lost again.
Yeah,
he did.
Including was again too.
Okay.
What did he lose to Henderson?
Look at all the fighters that strike force and ours is different.
I feel like that flight got canceled.
Maybe you're right.
Did Eddie get hurt in that?
Cause that's a hell of a surprise.
Why can I not remember that?
I can't remember.
We'd head shots.
All right.
Let's see.
You've been saying
this is your best fight on the card right here.
Yeah,
I agree.
Well,
you know what?
I'm very curious to see what happens in the main event.
I am too cause 2003
can you still see the Sweden?
Yeah.
It's just we keep Pete,
we're already at the Co main event.
Yeah.
There's not that many fights.
Is this a two hour show?
No,
I think so,
man.
We've been here one hour and we're already at the Co main event.
That's weird.
I also fight pests.
Yeah.
Eddie Alvarez lost a cowboy and they lost one more.
Okay.
The last fights for Benson were Brandon.
Thatch and then the Donald Cowboy Cerrone fight and then Hofeld dos Anjos.
I feel dos Anjos making fights up everybody.
Yeah,
I think that was a fight that was scheduled.
Supposed to happen and take place at his last fight because he's lost two.
I thought I didn't know that he lost to,
why do I not remember that?
You can just say
I love Google.
God,
it's awesome.
Sorry.
Oh,
Serone beat him and then who beat him after Serone though?
You'd beat Michael Gym.
I go to fight.
Know Michael Chandler.
Chandler was in Beltour.
Yeah,
you in UFC when you are who you looking at?
Jamie?
Sorry.
Eddie Alvarez.
Yeah.
He beat Michael Chandler to leave Bella tour.
It just says yes.
He wants seven.
I think he's only four at once,
dude.
And then he got hurt.
He was supposed to fight Ben,
right?
Yeah.
I don't think he's dumb.
Fight Pass went down again.
Mostly fipass fipass it keeps kicking me off and I have to re log in.
Okay.
This is really dumb.
I'm going to sign in with Facebook,
see if it makes a difference.
Okay.
Powerful.
Jimmy Martin.
Noah.
I love listening to the European commentators.
Yeah,
you're really,
they talk is only one fight was Donald.
You're trying to give him more losses because he's so handsome.
Dude.
His eyebrows are on point.
He's beautiful.
He for sure gets those waxed.
I'm mom really excited to see him adjust to the higher level of competition
cause I think he will.
You do?
Yeah.
I think you will.
Um,
I think he'd be,
I think you'd be surprised how high he needs some work with his leg kick
checking obviously.
Um,
I just don't think he ever fought a guy who has this as slick as Donald on his
feet.
When you say higher level guys who do,
who are you talking about?
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
I see potential in them.
I mean,
it all depends on the knowledge.
That's,
that's what I was going,
just going to say.
It all depends on how much damage he got through those Chandler fights and
fighting in Japan forever.
Set some hard fights,
some really crazy,
crazy wars.
He's a wild motherfucker.
I love watching him fight.
Me Too.
I love it,
man.
Yeah,
he's wild.
Great.
But what you know,
you know as well as I know when you have a wild style like that,
there's only so much fucking area on the board.
See that?
Yeah.
The Michael Chan,
the feds,
the higher level where the,
the pros pros go,
okay,
your wild check this out.
Yeah.
Well just you open yourself up,
you know,
and it makes it super exciting.
I mean,
we all know those guys who just go to a war at the beginning of every fucking
round just,
and they're super exciting to watch.
They're a fan favorite.
Yep.
And the next thing you know,
two years down the road,
you're fucking three and six sitting at home watching these guys who were
winning by wrestling and being smart and you can win that way.
That's what's kind of crazy.
Like sometimes you can win that way and when you win that way,
it's wild to watch.
So it's like no one,
it's,
if you win that way,
you did the right thing.
But if you want to look at it as a long term proposition,
can't fight that way.
You can't fight that way.
There's no way the longterm position is.
Yes.
Linda Garcia is a good example,
but you got to remember that the amount I'll takes on your brain.
Yeah.
Leonard was just a wild mother fucker.
So fun to watch.
So down.
This one's going to be wild.
Fuck yeah,
it is.
How do you say buck quotes?
How do you say his name?
Let's just call him Yan.
Let's do this.
Yan.
Yan,
let's talk like when I answer the barber said,
can I just get that chuck went to,
is there any way can just give me the truck l Yan Brockovich.
Damn.
Yawns beat some good guys,
man.
You gotta remember he beat that Latifi your mare.
Latifi has Manoa fought since.
Uh,
he fucked Gustafson.
Nope,
this is first fight.
So He's been working a lot of stuff.
Ooh.
Eaten at Gerard.
Jab by Jan.
Hard Jab.
Need a few more.
Those on to hometowns.
It's fought here before.
I don't know,
man.
I liked his chances,
although he's done a dog.
A good fucking job was one of the most underrated weapons,
man.
And the UFC.
I think it's still the most underutilized tool.
Even more than kicked.
Yeah.
I think kicks are definitely under utilized as well.
But man,
there's something about a jab.
It's so quick and effective.
Look at Musashi,
saucy look at GSP.
Yeah.
If you've got a real check jobs,
you can,
you can really disrupted guys striking.
Now would you say yens stiff?
Who that no thanks.
I liked the waste throwing that jab man.
I love the Jab.
I liked the jab.
Jimmy's a little more loose.
Got Man.
What?
Left talk.
That was pretty,
that left hook to the liver was nice.
Ooh,
that's the thing about Manoa man.
The amount of impact he puts on Shit,
you know,
super explosive.
Very exciting to watch.
Motherfucker can pop.
Like you said though,
you get to those higher levels,
man.
Ooh,
look at that.
Of the body.
Yeah.
I mean look,
Gustafson got them.
Uh,
that was a good fight.
Gustafson showed what he's made of in that fight.
This is a Gustafson,
Anthony Rumble Johnson stuff going back and forth on Twitter was um,
the headbutt well,
no,
it wasn't even that.
A lot of people have brought that up though.
You absolutely positive that it was a headbutt when you watch the tape?
Yes.
Yeah.
I want to watch it again.
Everybody seems like them to fight again though.
It seemed to me like it would just definitely a head,
but that's what it seemed like.
But I'm still,
I would like to watch it again before you,
I would say you know,
oh it was a headbutt.
It was one of those ones where he's throwing the right hand at the same time,
so I don't know what landed first if and when you watch the tape in slow motion,
it looked like the head doesn't have their way.
He beat him.
I don't give a shit in the right hand.
Yeah,
and the right hand did land behind the head.
It did land.
This is a question of which one fucked him up first the head,
but definitely if he did crack into them,
which I believe he probably did.
It looks like from the angle,
it's not one of those definite ones,
you know,
we could see absolutely side on.
Have you seen the heads collide?
Have you seen it?
Yeah,
it's Daddy.
Good.
Devin definitely head,
but we'll watch it again.
You're Alexander said he wanted to retire after that fight.
Yeah.
Hey man,
it's tough loss in front of your hometown home country.
Like that.
Tough love.
I can't wait to see him in clover fight next.
That's a good fight.
Great fight.
The good fight and both guys need it.
And Glover is,
you know,
I usually walked around like 230240220 that's good to 20 right now.
Well he realized in that last fight that he just didn't have the gas tank to go
to deal with Phil Davis and he also trained in like Connecticut in a garage.
Yeah.
It's,
I think that's all he had available,
is it?
Yeah.
He had to stay here.
Stay in town.
Really one for some reason I'm thinking about it had something to do with family
or it makes sense.
Yeah.
I think that was the story behind it.
So he put together his own crew down there of good guys.
But you know what man?
I mean,
how many do,
I don't have to tell you how many dudes don't have someone managing the
training.
How many dudes don't have someone who's like a Mark Henry type dude.
96% of the 96% I think that's the right,
the,
the main,
the main event.
And this Gabriel Gonzaga,
a guy who just has trained out of 10 yeah,
team link.
He's the fucking link.
He's the biggest dog in the gym for sure.
Knows the potential.
He could have had it if he would have went to Greg Jackson's or American top
team.
I agree.
He stays in Boston.
Well,
he's got a family and you teach,
get all that convenience.
But yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Well,
you know what man,
when Randy coture beat him,
he beat,
he beat him when he was in his total prime.
You know,
that was when Gonzaga
was in his prime and Randy just took it to him.
Even Gonzaga has prime's a fucking beast beast and knocking a lot of dudes out.
He's scared us.
I've ever been for a fight.
Hands down.
I was so scared.
Really terrified.
Mile.
Just because of the power,
the power world champion Jujitsu,
you know,
he's knocked out some fucking mods,
cro cop.
He's been in there against the best.
The Cro cop knock was terrifying.
That was the scariest I've ever been.
Wow.
I wish I could find that again.
I've gotta be honest for Real,
so I'm not scared anymore.
Do you think that's just because you've had so many experiences?
Yes.
And I in,
in the training room,
I go against scary dudes all the time.
So when I fight I'm not as scared.
It's not good man.
There's nothing like that fear of God and you to make you wow.
Yeah.
I see what you're saying.
It becomes almost too confident or too comfortable.
Yeah.
I've been too comfortable.
Daigo Chimi man was thrown some nasty kicks.
Dude is a lot of good power behind those kicks.
That was a good round.
Give it to Jimmy.
Yeah,
I hear what you're saying about Gonzaga God damn talented,
Huh?
Fuck what?
And he's,
he's really worked on his boxing,
his last few fights and I think that could be a really interesting aspect in
this fight.
No,
take them down some middle.
My man,
he had some Gonzaga on top.
You some of the best Jujitsu in the UFC.
Man.
Why do you think he abandoned that and just decided to bang?
You think it was cause of the wrestlers
now he took Shane Carwyn down if you're Merrill that he's kind of whipping
Shane's s yeah,
it was 40 seconds,
but he took chain down,
rock them,
took them down.
The Shane got up and said,
Oh cool story.
Boom,
Jab,
knockout.
Well,
he got a little careless.
He had shaved her and he got careless and he ran into a short punch that just
kicked the fucking generator down the street.
I was like,
oh my God.
It was a generator tumbling down the street with a cord following,
borrow.
That's what happened to his brain with that right hand.
And I also think Gonzaga has a mental issue with cardio.
So when you want to grapple wrestle guys,
especially in the UFC at this point,
it's going to take a lot of energy.
A lot of energy.
Man,
I think he's worried about that dude chain.
Carmen is probably the last guy you want to get hit with a short punch from
ever,
ever in the history of fighting the case.
Fucking,
they don't make them like Shit,
man.
They still build on that fucker.
It's just so ridiculous.
So much power and pretty loose with his fucking hands.
Fuck yeah.
Shane was an athletic that Frank Mir,
Kale.
Jesus fucking,
I'll never forget that.
Frank Mirs corns going,
God,
he's not doing shit here.
Just rest.
I'm like Ras.
It's an under hook.
He has an under hook and he's smashing uppercuts through with fucking for Roche.
This intention,
there was some of the best striking from the clinch and the heavyweight division
I've ever seen that one fight.
I don't think there's no,
I don't think there's any other heavyweight who can hit like Shane from an under
hook that would that much power.
He named someone who's not in new out like that.
No,
he hits you so fucking hard and he's fast and loose.
Even for a big giant to leverage.
Yeah,
he and he throws perfect punches.
I mean those are perfect power punches.
All Shane did his box.
I see.
I think his deal,
Shane's deal,
unfortunately in the UFC will always have been the injuries that he sustained
before he got to the UFC.
100% it's too bad because he was a real goddamn freak.
A real freak.
Best I've ever seen.
I've seen a lot of guys,
Shane,
in his prime,
when he's getting ready for a new Gonzaga is the best fighter I've ever seen.
We've seen a lot of dudes,
man,
that's strong words.
God Damn Dude,
Oh,
and he's a fucking engineer.
Shit.
Hell yeah.
Smarter Shit.
He's like a fucking thick professor x man.
When I hear about a dude like that,
it's,
you know,
the back issues just ultimately ended it and you think about all the hits that
he probably took and football and if you could erase those and see a guy like
that compete without coming in already fucked up in a certain extent and
wrestling mill to wrestling.
He said that took a lot out of them too,
man.
Yeah.
Got To imagine who wrestled these big giant motherfuckers.
What do you think of Todd Duffy?
Frank Mir.
Todd Duffy.
He's a beast.
Man,
Todd Todd Duffy throw some fucking heat,
too hot.
Duffy's a beast.
Todd Duffy and I were trading partners for awhile.
I like Todd.
Todd's biggest problem has always been himself.
His mind,
if,
if he's tentative against frank,
he's going to get destroyed.
If Todd Duffy performs like he doesn't,
the training room,
Todd Duffy is probably going to be fighting for a title and next year.
Wow.
Strong,
strong.
Whereas I also,
I also exaggerate everybody.
No,
for real.
So anyone who's ever trained with Todd asked DC,
asked Kane,
he's been at a k ass.
Everyone down in Florida,
h a t.
T,
he's been in Denver,
he's been to fucking every gym in America.
But if Todd performs like doesn't train room,
he's a fucking nightmare.
But when you see him in the AUC,
gun's just not there yet.
I Harry a man,
that makes sense.
You know,
um,
if you look at some of his finest moments,
he,
uh,
the Anthony Hamilton fight,
Goddamn,
he throws some fucking fast power punches still for sure.
But at the same,
Hamilton's not going to fucking,
you know Anthony Hamilton's a big boy too,
that those were Chris Punches.
Yeah,
they were straight down the pipe.
Yeah.
Anthony's just aid them.
Which you can't do at heavyweight.
Well,
Frank Mir,
how about that Fucking Jab,
left hook.
He landed on look,
fucking Lou nasty look loose.
I,
there's never been a fight.
That frank spot besides Shane Collin,
I don't root for Frank Mir.
What he's done for the sport.
I root for him.
Every single fos stats.
Now he's fighting traditional.
He used to be southpaw.
Traditionally he threw that Faint Jab,
left hook,
knock,
big foot out.
Big quotes.
A fucking nightmare man.
Do you wonder though?
I mean,
big foot went down pretty quick against our Lawsky and he went down pretty quick
against Frank Mir and we know for a fact that big foot,
if anybody needs testosterone replacement therapy,
it's foot.
I agree.
Big Foot
has a legit like tumor on his pituitary gland.
Apparently according to what the interviews that he's done,
he would have to get surgery and he's going to eventually get surgery to have it
removed.
You know,
but his testosterone is not like normal persons.
You can't find the UFC then man,
I hate to be shitty about it because I'm a big foot.
He's one of the nicest guys.
These what do you require that and you can't find the UFC.
Right and because I want the same shit.
You're taking that right.
That's a good point.
That's good.
I need a bigger head.
Give me the same shit you're taking,
but you would have to if you,
you would,
if you were going to do that,
if you're going to let people do it,
you would have to be monitoring them all times the day to make sure they're not
putting superhuman levels in and then everybody would have like a level of
testosterone they're allowed to achieve.
Like you never going to happen.
Maybe you wear a fucking Iwatch.
Yeah,
right.
You were reports back to the UFC had checks in every day.
I mean that's not outside the realm of possibility.
They have watches and tell your fucking heartbeat now.
True.
It's kind of a good idea.
If they could figure out a way to test your testosterone.
Maybe just point your camera at your Dick every day and it would know just by
the way to Dick's moving and then your testosterone goes up in a real high,
right?
Like if I'm a lady's man just destroying chicks,
I'm like,
God damn shops testosterone was like nine times.
Hi This Day.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
That could be,
yeah.
If you could be around a bunch of pretty ladies,
man,
he body gears up for war.
I'm in La.
Someone in Idaho's probably not the same.
You know?
You know they say that that's true that men around attractive women,
like literally their bodies produced 100% you know what else?
Engines like a rumbling engine,
like a v eight like you're American for sure.
For whatever reason that makes your body produce more testosterone.
They have no idea why,
because it sounds like a fucking dragon man
machine
and I don't mean war machine.
The fighter.
Yeah,
definitely not.
it's crazy.
When you think about the things that actually make your body produce more
hormone,
chicks and cars,
man,
what else?
What else?
Isn't it funny though that you're criticized for being a,
a foolish person if you enjoy hot chicks and cars?
Yeah.
Oh,
such a meathead new flu.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to my fucking DNA to love big ass titties and Porsche's by bat.
Yeah.
You're sorry that you enjoy some of the most fun things ever.
I'm sorry because it makes you dumb.
Like there cannot be one without the other.
No,
man,
I'm here.
What's going on here?
Why?
How come they have began the wrong yet?
Doo,
Doo doo too powerful UK.
Here we go.
Round two,
three,
three.
Did I say too?
Yeah,
we didn't even talk about the second round.
We just talked about titties,
kitties and why we love him not to judge us.
Jeez,
man.
Yeah.
It's funny that certain things are thought of to be,
uh,
for fools,
but PR cool cars are one of them.
For whatever reason you,
you never,
you never going to see like a science professor that drives a sick that now it's
weird,
but seek vet and just have a girlfriend with a blowout ass if you don't try it.
I mean,
Neil degrasse Tyson's is probably the closest,
but you'd have to like put on a mask and a corvette,
you know,
if some people wouldn't take him seriously if he was balling and a sweet
corvette.
Yeah.
There's no college professors out there with Ferrari's and girlfriends is big.
Is Einstein was allowed motherfucker.
He was like a rock star.
He that was pre Twitter.
Yeah.
Before we got judged by everyone.
He married,
he married his cousin.
That's pretty gangster.
It's pretty weird.
If he had,
he had,
he had a first marriage,
had a couple kids,
wasn't that great of a father according to this documentary.
And then ended up marrying his cousin and she became like his manager too.
And he was allowed Damien,
he was allowed to see anybody he wanted,
like he,
and she was cool with it.
Sounds awesome.
That's why he's the smartest guy.
Has his cousin looked like she,
she,
she loved them.
She was schlubby down.
She loved her.
They just made a deal.
But they were,
they made a deal.
So the deal was when girls,
um,
would come over,
they'd have to bring her chocolate.
That was a requirement.
It chocolates,
chocolates.
Now we will suck your man's Dick now and then we'll jump in the car and
disappear for a couple of days.
Does a good deal.
Einstein was a mad player.
Damn.
I did not know.
Yeah.
Jimmy Manawan.
I had no idea it was a rockstar.
I like him even more.
I hate him even more.
Yeah,
you can't,
you know.
Oh,
Lou had kik.
Um,
you know,
who's allowed to that are sort of scientists?
Well,
they're not scientists,
but they're super geniuses.
They're allowed to get those kind of cars is like video game designers.
True.
Those super geniuses like the John Carmack type characters.
You know what that guy does in his spare time?
Oh,
nothing just makes rockets.
Really.
Yeah.
It makes his own sockets.
He's the,
the,
the lead software guy.
The,
the lead designer.
Whatever the lead computer genius at a quake id a it game creek.
I don't know what the actual name of the studio.
It's just aid.
But uh,
they created doom.
They created quake one,
quake two,
quake three quake.
Uh,
yeah,
they,
they made a bunch of fucking crazy games that John Carmack guy in his spare
time,
he turbo charges Ferrari's.
He takes a fraud.
Right?
It's like not strong enough.
Have a solution and he bolts gigantic turbocharges to Ferrari.
You're looking dude too.
It's not a bad looking guy.
Really.
Yeah.
He's does judo to share judo.
Jujitsu.
You live in La.
I only live down in Texas.
He said he's a bad motherfucker.
He's a legit super genius.
Like I,
you know,
I have dull mind as it were,
but when I talked to like legit super geniuses,
I'm usually okay.
Like I can talk to them about this,
but when I'm with Carmax I'm like,
don't make mistake.
Stay on road
nervous.
Say the wrong word.
Don't talk about shit.
You don't know.
Stay in your life.
Don't pretend
standing fucking lane.
Like if you're on a motorcycle and you're following a guy who was a motorcycle
racer and you're trying to keep up with them and you know,
you shouldn't be driving this fast and just don't pop wheelies.
She'll not student and ask questions.
Yeah,
man,
that's question.
Yes,
absolutely.
I'm trying to make statements.
Well,
he's just,
he would talk about programming.
We would talk about code and coding.
How old is Karmic?
It's a good question.
Is he like a Doogie Howser kid?
Genius.
He's like 40 now because he quit.
His quake has been around for a long time.
I mean,
they created quake I think in the early nineties I don't remember what year it
was.
Would you rather be a super athlete like Michael Jordan or straight fucking
genius,
like an Einstein or your boy?
They see,
I don't think they're mutually exclusive.
I think that the only way really genetically,
I think it's very possible that you can get a guy who has a physical talents of
Michael Jordan and has an insanely powerful brain.
It's totally possible.
However,
both not.
It's not true and the history look,
it's,
it's just,
it's possible.
But the thing is,
in order to have that much knowledge in your head and not much data,
I can mean you're not going to be in a jam and you never gonna reach that level.
He,
it'll just be one or the other.
In terms of what you focus your attention on,
but in terms of having the brain that has the capacity to reach like super
genius levels,
I don't think they're mutually exclusive.
We just,
I'm just guessing,
but I don't take the hundred smartest guys in the world.
Oh,
not very good at Jimmy Manoa going,
I don't think they would look like you can take the hundred smartest guys in the
world.
They looked like Mr Barren,
low,
low hit.
They looked like Mr. Burns like shit.
Oh,
it wasn't that.
That was the end of the fight.
I thought it was a low shot that there were separating them.
That was,
I think that one's going to decision young black,
which is a tough motherfucker.
That's his name.
Right,
is going to be tough for Jimmy to get a decision when in John's hometown.
I think that UFC probably brought Polish commissions one.
Is it a Polish commission?
I would imagine because they have big promotions out there.
Was it a k something that's a big promotion.
That yon was a previous champ of,
how'd he say?
Bellaco which block of Itch?
The lockup,
which is tough as fuck dude,
that guy can take a beating.
That was a good fight.
He's going to feel that one tomorrow
as is Manoa.
Who bed?
Yeah.
Not too bad.
No,
but I mean a lot of shots to the body from Manoa throws those nasty niece.
The body man.
We were watching the sac around close enough.
We were talking all kinds of shit about booties,
mustangs and Shit and geniuses.
Corvettes that are lasar that Bob was our guy.
Remember that guy?
Yeah.
That guy had a corvette that was hydrogen powered.
He made it hydrogen powered him.
He took a corvette and converted the engine to run on hydrogen.
What a crazy story is because because of either way,
what he saying is,
uh,
an incredible story.
Either he's telling the truth or if he's lying,
he's one of the greatest actors.
Cause he's so smart.
He's,
you got to be able to fake some genius shit and have people,
do you know about it?
No.
Eddie,
explain and tell them what problems are.
You're better at explaining that shit than I am.
What's Bob Dunn bobblehead czar was a former scientist according to him was a
former scientist.
He worked at area 51 they brought him in because he was a scientist and because
he knew a lot about propulsion,
propulsion systems and and theoretical propulsion systems.
He's like,
I guess he's a physicist or something like that.
I don't know what is his background as far as education because it's in dispute
as a lot of people that say that he fudged is I say bullshit.
Who knows?
However,
this guy says that he was working in area 51 and he was working on something.
They brought him in to back engineer a Ufo.
They brought him in and they took him to some,
this is him right here.
They took him into some hanger that has,
yeah,
he Matt magic and,
well dude,
it's not about that.
What I'm saying is this dude was working on what they were explaining to him,
nothing,
but what he believed over time was that what he was working on was back
engineering a Ufo from another world.
Damn.
Do you believe him?
He has skeptical hit on most convincing of all the people that have ever heard
discussed these.
That's really the most convincing.
Is it all down?
He doesn't antigravity and how it works and everything.
He doesn't seem like an idiot at all.
He definitely seems like a fucking very,
very,
very intelligent dude.
He doesn't seem like he's lying because he wrote lots of books.
No,
I don't believe so.
I don't know how many books he's wrote,
but I'm too dumb to know whether or not he stupid too.
I don't know.
And you know what I mean?
Like I'm too dumb.
Like he sounds right,
but it could be like some martial arts guy that's talking all kinds of mad
nonsense.
What his,
you know his Ci Gong is going to do to you if you get near him and if you're
not,
my friend knows a guy with a cheat gone fucking it's on your chest mad.
That's where we're at right now.
There's guys that believe that.
So,
and if someone speaks well enough,
we sort of like assume they know what the fuck they're talking about.
And I listened to him talk and he sounds like he knows what the fuck he's
talking about.
It's a very compelling story.
Money off saying any of this.
I'm sure he has.
I would imagine you,
if you really want to get into it,
you'd have to Google it because I haven't really read about it and about seven
or eight years,
I kind of put it behind me.
I kind of decided somewhere along the line there was no fruit in this pursuit
because they couldn't figure it out whether or not he had lied about his
educational background.
They couldn't figure out whether or not he had actually worked for the
government.
But this shit.
Right.
Well they found out that he did work for one of the labs that he said he worked
for.
He worked for like Los Alamos.
They did find out that that was true.
So how the fuck did he get that job if you didn't have like a super high level
education,
but who knows what the fuck he was doing there when he was working there?
People that are like real scientists have a lot of doubts about all the shit
that he said.
That's pretty much enough for me,
but if I just want to have fun,
I want to pretend that tomorrow if I want to pretend,
because it is fun to pretend there's,
there's so much,
there's so much footage of him being interviewed and explaining how it all
works.
He's an amazing actor.
He's full of Shit.
I'm just too stupid to understand it easily be full of shit,
but fuck,
this guy's good.
He's super smart.
It sounds like he knows what he's talking about when it,
when he's discussing antigravity but,
but when you call these other scientists coming out and being like,
this dude's full of shit.
Well when I say that also be Freeman.
He,
yeah,
he's probably a bit of a hater buddy.
Make some good points,
man.
You can't.
The guy's got to produce,
when you say you graduated from,
fill in the blank,
MIT,
whatever it is,
you should be able to display a degree.
Do you have a degree or you are in their records and if you're not in their
records and if you can't display a degree,
you never got a degree,
then I have to dispute everything you've said agree degree.
But is it possible that,
especially we're talking about something a long time ago,
is it possible that someone could go back to the records at that school in,
scrub him from the records?
Come on.
Here's why it's not possible yearbooks.
True.
Someone will like a yearbook,
wouldn't one of just his classmates were like,
yeah,
I was in class with them.
Yeah.
So when we come out back I was in class stuff.
Fucking doors.
Yeah.
Well he should be able to name his professors should be able to can't.
Huh?
I don't know.
You know from one I'll share.
Yeah.
From what I have read,
I would say he hasn't,
but who knows how much of what I've read is the truth or what Eddie was saying.
Cause I know five graduate from Harvard,
I have a fucking Harvard shirt on right now.
You guys would hear about it nonstop.
Do you ever hear the lies of slessinger story about Yale?
No.
She's a friend of mine though.
Google it.
Eliza slash.
Manager.
No,
no,
no.
It's not bad for her.
It's she dated this guy that was pretending.
He's telling me the story on the podcast,
the shit.
She got catfished and the dude said he is from Yale.
Dot.
Just catfish.
Like this dude made up a story about his mom having cancer.
This dude made up his job.
He made up his house,
made up that he was rich when he's really like $100,000 in debt.
He wasn't even at broke.
He made a Facebook profile.
I don't know what it really was.
Hey,
McCafe is,
he's just a fucking compulsive liar and then you got a credit card and take her
out to fancy dinners and shit.
Be racked up all this money on a credit card.
We didn't have the money,
dude.
He was a on an airplane with her guys.
A heroin.
My book.
Just kidding.
Was like,
well,
she's not dumb,
which is really weird.
She's a sharp girl.
Well,
that's what's really weird about it.
It's like,
how did you get caught with this?
Like how did you,
I mean,
I guess you don't mean,
this seems like so many lies,
so I could do,
you didn't get tripped up anywhere.
I mean,
what was he telling the truth about?
You know,
she said,
she said though he would lie about his mom being sick or nine and so she didn't
want to get too into it.
So it was almost a wall,
you know,
like you don't want to dive into someone's mom dying.
Right.
But the guy was smart,
but people who were full of shit are they,
they're full of shit.
I mean,
how good was this guy in regular conversation?
Must be a great Ralf Tori Rafael,
Tory,
Eddie Bravo and I both have a story about a guy that was completely full of
shit.
He was a fake black belt.
It's awesome of total fake black belt.
And when Eddie first introduced me to him,
he was a reporter for websites.
He was going and doing these,
uh,
the early MMA reporting and he would do like Gonzo journalist questions.
I think they were describing it as like he would ask dude's if they like fucking
girls on the butt,
like weird,
weird,
weird questions.
And he was telling everybody that he was a black belt in Jujitsu and then Eddie
rolled with them and Eddie was like,
Oh man,
I don't know.
Maybe it was just like going really lie still.
And he was smart.
He was smart.
He,
he said that,
uh,
he was half Brazilian and half Italian and his dad is Brazilian,
was a,
a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu and that he knew all the old guys,
but he came from the judo side.
So he was smart.
He said we were more judo guys.
We were old school Jujitsu than my dad gave me a black belt when I was 18 or
whatever.
And we're not as good as like nowadays,
Jujitsu,
so complex.
And so we evolved.
We're not that gun,
I'll admit that because he's just flat valuable.
I'm a black belt,
but I'm old school black belt.
So he wasn't,
he was smart.
So believable.
I bet he was so nervous when you have to roll with you.
Do you roll them to Joe?
No,
I never rolled them.
I wasn't really good friends with them.
Eddie was not,
I mean you weren't even good friends though,
but I only hung out with him.
We worked together on what he was a writer for.
Um,
the underground.
He was like the rider yet for the EEG.
And he was always at shows that I would commentate like king of the cage.
I still ride for him.
No jail.
He's in jail for murder.
This is where it gets really,
really escalated.
Oh Dude,
this is where it gets really crazy.
Uh,
so I'll take you back to when Eddie,
Eddie exposed him and Eddie,
we were driving back from like,
what was it like King of the cage?
What were you driving back from some,
one of those MMA fights way out in the middle of nowhere.
It was,
it wasn't that I exposed him.
Yeah,
he was all ready to explode.
That was the last one.
You know,
dudes pulled me to the side and said this and that.
And,
and uh,
I mean in a phone call to his face.
Yes.
You mean you,
you basically,
you,
you confronted him.
Yes.
It was pretty intense,
but it was a pretty intense call.
We were driving.
I was driving and Eddie was right next to me.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Yukon Denali.
Really remember the conversation?
I barely remember.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
You were going to do dude,
stop lying to me.
Stop lying to me.
Really?
You weren't not a black belt in Jujitsu?
Did he admit it?
Dude,
you are.
Listen to me.
You're a fucking liar.
You're lying.
You're not a black belt in Jujitsu.
Do you know how crazy it is?
And you tell me you were a black belt in Jujitsu.
I cannot let Eddie Bravo.
He was,
it was,
it was pretty crazy.
And you could hear him like stammering and stuff
for sure.
Put that on speaker phone.
I wish I could remember all the shit that you said,
but you broke it down and in,
in an undeniable way.
Then he killed a guy.
You're a crazy person.
Then when Robert Killed Eddie Bravo cuts and got off,
okay.
He cuts him off.
And then our friend Gerald a street bet.
Who was Eddie's first black belt,
right?
No,
Danny probit ghosts was your first black belt?
When was,
uh,
he was my,
Gerald [inaudible] was my first,
uh,
before I even had a school.
He was my first student that did MMA before there was no thought of 10 planet.
I was just showing jailed street Vincent Jujitsu.
I was compensated for King of the cage and that's how I met Gerald.
He was,
he was Rafael student.
Crazy.
Okay.
So Eddie comes and teaches them some real shit,
has a bunch of real fights.
Um,
he gets contacted by this guy cause he,
the guy wants him to kill his girlfriend's husband.
He tells Gerald he wants me to kill his girlfriend's husband,
was going to give him a certain amount of money.
And Cheryl's like,
what the fuck?
So Gerald goes to the cops.
No,
Jared goes to the cups after he killed himself,
the guy killed himself,
choked him,
apparently like had him come meet him at the gym.
Choked him to death,
killed him and then was seen driving around in his car.
What a dumb ass dude.
It's crazy.
It was driving around in homeboys car.
I don't think so.
You don't have to be to know how to rear naked choke somebody.
You know,
you sneak up behind some fucking fat ass who doesn't work out at all and you get
a hold of his neck.
I mean he wasn't like completely inept as a martial artist.
He know.
He was like a kind of an amateur martial artists.
Like there's some videos of him throwing a spinning back kick on a pad.
They're kind of hilarious.
It's kind of hilarious.
It really is.
Like,
you know you getting a hold of Dunkin and teaching Dunkin suspending back kicks
for a couple of weeks and then having them hit the pad.
It's fucking,
it's fucking but positive.
It's weird is this guy's been lying the whole time.
Then he kills the guy.
This is where it gets crazy.
He kills the guy.
And then he gives Gerald burry.
Before that though,
before that,
before the murder,
he set up a fake fight and king of the cage.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
against his big Samoan guy.
It was totally fake.
And he,
they,
they kept their mouth shut.
They made it happen.
So he ends up getting this big giant Samoan guy like the shittiest neba cause I
couldn't be bothered.
It's like that.
And the guy starts tapping anyone.
So,
and fight was his comeback
fight.
He told everybody he was 14.
I know in MMA,
but there were all undocumented fight.
He was,
he was doing,
I commentated that fight and I was saying,
hit Rafael Torah returns to MMA to,
uh,
um,
to defend is undefeated record.
I'll take it to the next level.
Everybody do.
He wasn't 14 though.
He never fought ever.
I'll take it to the next one.
That's awesome.
I'll take you to the next level.
He had a friend drive him out to the woods and he brought with him a giant
duffle bag.
Okay.
He told his friend,
drive me out to the woods.
I want about to compete in a no rules Kuma [inaudible] you know,
if I win I'm going to make a lot of mine or come back with the first place.
And this is Lauren again because it's true story.
Yeah,
sure.
So he says to do come back tomorrow.
Okay.
This was a newspaper journalist,
a newspaper writer.
He took the local guy and he said,
Roger knows,
because I haven't told anybody,
but I'm going to go in the woods,
there's going to be this cool tech.
What's wrong?
He goes,
but I need you.
I want you to write the story on this,
but you're going to drop me off like I can't show you where it's going to be.
So the dude,
the newspaper writer drops him off like in the middle of nowhere in the woods
and he says,
come back from me in two days.
Right.
And the guy had a big duffle bag with him.
It was something long in it.
Right.
So the guy comes back two days later and picks him up.
So he was like camping out there.
Right.
He had like camp in a criminal.
He came up and then he had this giant trophy says I won the Cooma town.
Oh my God.
That motherfucker packed a joke.
So,
so what does the writer do naturally?
He writes a story on it.
He takes that story,
frames it,
and put the,
puts it up out of school.
Five bananas proof.
So,
but it happened.
It was in the newspaper.
That's so God damn crazy.
He's a genius.
And she got a legit fighter coming out right now.
He's cop,
the Cro Cop Scott,
a raw,
a lot of redness on his nose.
First of all,
we don't know.
He didn't go to a Kuma tag.
Oh No,
no.
It is evidence that we do,
but we do.
So let me wrap this story up real quick.
So,
uh,
Gerald calls me and tells me that the guy gave him the gun or some point that I
forget what the conversation was.
I was like,
what?
Huh?
Jesus fucking Christ.
And then Gerald gets ahold of the cops.
And apparently they were,
they were,
uh,
tapping his phone.
So the cops called me and they want to know what I know about the murder.
And I explained to him,
I go,
look,
I know almost nothing.
What I know is what you know Gerald told me cause the guy was,
they were listening in on our conversation so to say what I know is what Gerald
told,
I told him everything.
I know what Gerald told me.
The guy's a crazy liar.
He's a fake black belt.
I don't know if he really killed the guy or not.
Like it's very conceivable and this guy is so fucking crazy.
He made that up to you.
Might not even killed somebody at this point.
At least I think this is pretty much proven.
Betty killed the guy now.
Fuck.
But so he's got involved in it.
Two minutes of don't bring me to court.
Come on.
Don't bring me to court.
Cause I met
Rafael Toria at Eddie's house.
Don't drag me.
And then it gets even darker because Gerald killed somebody one day sake.
Smelled killed somebody like a year ago in a traffic related incident,
some guy and him were having some road rage incident and it got physical.
Gerald was actually on the phone with nine one one and he fucking shot this dude
and now he's in jail and he's on trial right now to Gerald.
Some guy tried to run them off the road.
Some guy was drunk.
Joe Wasn't drunk.
I mean the guy that was shot was drunk.
He rammed him like he stopped his car,
pulled it in reverse and random like they were having like some road rage
incident and that guy was drunk.
General gets out of his car.
He had,
he lives in Oregon,
he has a rifle,
he has his rifle and the guy's talking shit and he's coming form and Gerald
start,
he's like on the other side of the car and calling nine one one he said,
you know,
don't get near me dude.
I'm calling nine one one don't get near me.
The guys talking shit.
The guy came to him and Gerald thought he,
he had a gun too and he pulled it out and he shot him.
God does that.
What Gerald told you?
Yeah,
that's what he told you.
That was a conversation.
That is,
it is self to Hololens.
Exactly how the guy was drunk.
He runs them off the road,
he rammed him.
That's all you need.
He gets out with his gun,
gone.
What the fuck?
This guy is nuts.
The guys coming for him.
He was drunk.
Gerald shot him.
He was on nine,
nine one one saying I've got this crazy guy who's a who,
who just tried to run me off the road.
I'm standing right here,
you know.
And the guy kept coming to go stand back seeing people that boom two people are
basing the possibility that Gerald might have been more of an instigator based
on some of the things that he wrote on Facebook.
Apparently he had written something about like get out of my way when you're on
the road or something about some and had been involved in some other sort of
road rage type incident but,
but who the fuck knows Matt?
And also we have to deal with the fact that Gerald we know for a fact
experienced a lot of action overseas.
Oh really?
Served on any,
came back and did some tours for like one of those.
Um,
it's tough.
Uh,
you know,
when they call them contractors all like Blackwater Shit.
Yeah.
Did a common dose to finance his,
um,
to finances gym.
Fuck man.
You know,
so there's that and that's undeniable,
man.
That's,
that fucks with a person's head.
And when you're thinking about a person in,
in,
in an aggressive type situation,
and you've been in war before,
you're used to people trying to kill you and you've got to kill them first.
And Gerald is in a different place.
He's in a different place.
In the average person,
the average person that says,
you know,
hey,
you can't consider the fact that he was in the war and he had PTSD.
That doesn't little shit.
That does mean something.
100% should be like,
listen man,
he's under a different set of rules to,
there's some people that there's big misconceptions about martial
artists that a true martial artist would have not used the gun,
would have used his martial arts to handle the situation.
But that's all bullshit.
The more martial arts you,
you learn,
the more you know,
you need a goddamn gunning your house.
You need some guns because you're your martial arts.
The more you learn it,
you realize that's last resort.
When it's a life and death situation.
If it's an a sport or you know,
a controlled environment,
that's one thing.
But you know a general thought the guy had a gun.
The guy tried to run him off the road.
He's got a gun.
You're not going to drop your gun and double leg of them and try to arm on hell.
No,
no.
Yeah.
It's tough,
man.
It's lots.
How the story,
if I have a gun and there's some crazy shit going down,
guys drunk,
I'm a monster,
I'm going to shoot the me.
No rear naked choke.
Who knows if this guy has a gun you don't know.
So that's tough.
If that's exactly how it went down.
I agree with you 100% obviously I'm not questioning anything,
but I was not there so I don't know.
No,
I do not know he was on,
he was on nine one one when this happened and stuff.
He was already in the situation before the shot.
The shot is actually,
it's tough.
Con on nine one one call.
So
that's a crazy case.
Then why was the,
why did they have him in jail?
Still there if that's exactly how it was happening and if he really deal with a
madman as a veteran,
you think they'd show him a little leeway?
Because I was a veteran.
Another,
there's history of pass road rage,
but that has nothing to do with this just because you have a history of past
road rage,
you know?
Depends if he's shot like six motherfucker previous exact,
then we have a problem.
It'd be shooting people.
Yes,
but there are no damn 30 fibers.
40 wow.
All right.
This is it.
The main event,
ladies and gentlemen,
main event,
the fucked up shit as they got them in solitary confinement this whole time.
It's already over a year and a trial don't start till January and he's in
solitary.
It's fucking bullshit.
Man.
Here in Hernandez murdered like 19 why?
Why did they put him in solitary?
They're fucking,
they're just railroading him,
man.
Why do they get to that?
Something has to be going on.
We have to be missing a piece of the story.
I feel like you'd see in this fucked over.
So they're trying to say that,
uh,
there's uh,
that he has,
you know,
people have said he's,
he's been involved in road rage or fall.
I don't know if it's like documented officially,
but as something to do with that.
But that has nothing to do with this situation.
It's tough,
man.
That dude was drunk.
The guy that got killed,
he was wasted.
Gerald was not drunk,
was not wasted.
He was coming from the supermarket.
These are all facts,
but you just add them on nine.
He had them on nine one one he was talking,
he was on nine one one tell him the guy to back off,
back off.
He's,
he keeps walking towards his back off and then he popped him.
Jesus Christ.
It's on the,
it's on the record.
So they're fucking a man.
They're,
they're totally fucking him.
He's in solitary.
I feel like we're missing a piece of the story.
Who knows?
We don't know.
We don't,
we don't know.
Get fucked.
And I agree that does happen.
Some people just have fact and he's getting fucked.
This a cro captain's og isn't go two ways.
It's either,
it'd be one of the saddest things we've ever watched,
or it can be a fucking classic.
Well,
you got to think that Miraco wants that wind back.
That was,
that was one that probably haunts him.
That was his,
a big fight in the UFC is second.
Second event,
right.
Eddie Sanchez was his first fight and then he fought Gonzaga is for a title shot
to one of those in your kind of shot.
Damn,
that's crazy.
As Randy was a few merit,
Randy was Kate's side and he was like,
man,
I'd rather fight Cro,
cop Gabriel Gonzaga's to well rounded,
if you remember that.
Wow.
Golden Dog.
You know what,
man,
there's something about Gonzaga when he walks on the scale,
you know when I do the Wayans yeah,
he sounds different than everybody else really sounds like he's made out of
stone.
Like when he walks,
it's like,
don't tell you what man.
I fought both of them and Mirko Cro cop is the strongest guy I've ever fought.
Bar none.
Not even close.
Wow.
He was like a fucking like Shane Carwyn strong.
Even even more so like shaking can kind of move.
Boom pop.
It was like moving like the thing from fantastic for,
he was like,
it's like cro cop was made of straight rocks.
Jesus Christ.
Really?
I've heard people say the same thing about Dan Henderson but cro cop.
Yeah.
Listen,
I fought a roid it up fucking Lavar Johnson.
He was nowhere near as strong as try and give it a try given
Dan Henderson a back rub.
You break your hand.
I bet he will.
Harrison's made out a would do it the same as Susan.
She says it's just a beast.
He's made out of wood.
He didn't make a cro cop was due.
Do Strong.
That's interesting man.
Crazy right.
He developed a lot of really good takedown defense in pride.
If you look at his first fights in pride,
like the first fight with Vandelay when they had those red handed Fulbright
hands.
Well cause I just tight enough his boxing a lot man.
Yeah,
he has,
well you got to remember too,
is cro cop early in his career he flew out for doom before for doom was really
anything to work on his grappling.
Yeah.
That was his grappling coach.
Oh,
we tagged them.
Hit Man.
That right hands finding a home.
That's not good.
What do you think about this fight if you had a gas before it started?
Uh,
I never pick against girl cop man.
He's one of my heroes,
but objectively analytical Gonzaga has been fighting in the UFC for a lot
longer,
higher,
higher level Cro.
Cop really hasn't come is looking very fast here too.
Does that double right hand?
It just seems like cro cop over his last few fights.
He just,
he doesn't pull the trigger.
he's coming,
he's coming off two wins against a ichi.
Obviously that was in Jamaica,
but he,
she is much smaller than him to eat.
She shorter each.
She's every bit of 260 pounds.
Why?
She's of judo,
gold medalist I with [inaudible]
62 63 60 I think he,
he might when he's in crazy shape cut down to 45 that's insane.
I had no idea.
I thought he was about 205 fuck no,
he,
she is deck.
That's crazy.
Super Thick.
And for him to be ICI twice on a toughie.
She is man.
He's a fucking monster.
Good kick to the body.
Bygones og.
Okay.
Morocco is not pulling the trigger of that much.
There's an extra kick cause he doesn't want to get taken down.
He knows if he gets taken down.
He's in big trouble.
Some of the best takedown defense ever in the UFC.
I what'd they say?
He's forethought.
Time heavyweights.
I think
I tried taking Gonzaga and I tried double again.
My face hit the ground so fast.
He's sprawled every bit of fucking whatever it is to 60 on my little neck.
Oops.
A bit tentative and go and toggle.
It keeps doing that.
That lunging double right hand cro,
cop.
Just look at the clock.
That's a bad sign,
man.
We're fucking two 30 into it.
Well,
maybe he had a plan of waiting until the round before you open,
you don't think his corner could speak in Croatia.
Jesus.
There's deep,
deep,
deep double who he's going to pass.
Half it.
Guardia Cro,
cop's guard retention is pretty good.
It's not that he is very good defenseman.
Yeah,
it's not that bad.
But this is motherfuckers heavy.
Oh Elliot heavy and a world champ.
Yeah.
World Champ.
[inaudible] black belt.
Legit black elite and you can get guns.
I get down from his back.
He's not such a threat but on top man.
That's his game.
Yeah,
he's got a lock down and look at this.
We have a strong control.
Can't get out of that fucking half card.
Huh?
It's got gotta be careful.
The explosion is still there.
This is trouble,
man.
Cro Cop has always been like real explosive,
crazy explosive.
I'm going to have a cro,
cop and garden and got his feet on my hip and they couldn't get any worse.
Good luck.
And this is what he's worried about too is the elbows.
He was talking about this,
that that was the big difference in the first fight.
And he said that MMA probably should get rid of elbows because it causes a lot
of blood and people don't want to see blood and focus less on the ground.
I thought that was crazy and ridiculous.
That didn't make any sense at all.
It was a damn look at that.
It was always not show you how he's tapping.
He's happy.
He's tapping these tablets.
Not yet.
Dad's ran tab as he went down to,
he looked like he was tapped scrambles.
Oh Hey.
Maker in the guard.
I thought he was tapping.
I couldn't see his hand,
but it looked like he was reaching for it like right away.
That was a bad position.
I was nasty.
That was a funky angle on TV.
I want to see that against Gonzaga.
Using this grappling.
He's gonna be tough to beat,
man.
I'm impressed with the cro cop recovering back to full guard.
If he asked me,
he,
I agree.
He was mounted and now he's on a mountain anymore.
Yup.
And he almost got his laptop sign that he could do.
He could recover,
uh,
he can to bump him off the mountain.
Several Times.
I've worked with for doom and dean lister for years for a long,
long time and his defense going to be solid.
Yeah.
He's,
he's well trained.
He's not easy to get to a summit man.
He's just not at the level where he can attack now.
[inaudible] I don't think he wants to be either.
Well against this guy.
He went for that heel hook man,
that's pretty nasty tab random into member.
He got back in the does I?
I think when cro cop goes in the fight,
that's the least of his concerns is submitting somebody that was the second
fight after random and Kayla,
I remember that shit.
Yeah,
it's Christ Randleman lunged in and Christ on my days man,
they were crazy.
I don't know if we'll ever see banners fighting and then there were wild man and
you know what is one of them wild plants.
He didn't know who the fuck is going to fight until about a week out.
Yeah.
It's like,
oh sweet man.
They were constantly adding,
it was like an ice house show and just
they were constantly adding fighters.
Like I put together those ice house shows like four days out.
How cool would those days where you had two giant,
the Jit Evan Bayh organizations for the fans?
It was the ultimate went back and pretty amazing.
He left see this knee then pride steps over.
Oh,
right there.
Cro Cop for a second.
We did a good job.
Oh No.
He wasn't looking to tap at all.
He was looking to get that arm onto the leg.
Yeah.
Damn.
It wasn't as threatening as I thought it was in the scramble.
Pretty wild,
but it wasn't as close as any guy is.
Cardio issues between these two.
It's Gonzaga.
He's always had some issues when he thinks later in the rounds.
Do you think that's because of training a team link and not training at like att
or something like that?
I didn't push enough.
Probably like when you're always a bully,
when you're on top,
it's easy to go three rounds,
try being on bottom,
getting the worst case scenario,
you know,
getting bad positions.
Right,
and you got to get used to moving in those positions,
whereas you're not tired.
Right.
[inaudible] you're developing technique and you're developing endurance when
you're moving in those positions when you're tired.
Yeah.
And that's something that people kind of don't know until they get in there and
do it and you're not going to panic.
Like I'm sure cro crop was in mount during camp.
He didn't panic down there.
He got out of it.
Got Back to guard.
Yeah.
But if guns are going to get him to the ground like that again,
yeah,
he's in trouble.
Yeah.
It's interesting man.
You got to,
he is one of those,
I mean we're watching him in the main event right now,
so obviously everything's going well,
but he's one of those guys.
You got to wonder what if he did go to Jackson's?
What if he did?
That's what I'm saying,
man.
What if he did when he was with his skill set?
Really good.
He is with stand up.
Woo Dr under that cap.
Beautiful.
Oh good luck.
Nice knee to the body.
You're not taking him down against the case on dude nasty and you're not taking
him down against the cage where that one goes to the junk.
Yeah.
Hit Him.
Right.
And that Croak up there.
Do you remember the one with check Congo or was that one
that was attack against decks but really it was an assault on
Kokagni inside the cage is not happening.
You got taken down the open man.
That was our game plan.
God,
I just don't like Cro cop complex.
So he's just going to eat a right hand at any second.
He could double right hand is which Gonzaga is Wu missed again.
No.
And I liked about Gonzaga's leg attack was a,
he was completely safe from being punched.
That was an angle.
He jumped on that foot and that was a safe position.
Yeah.
If he would have cranked it a little better or had a better angle at it.
Cause usually you see when guys go for leg locks or knee bars,
they're usually eating punches.
It all depends on the angle.
Especially if you shoot up for a leg lock and the guy's still standing.
If you can get to be a strong base,
look at this.
Boom.
Oh Damn.
Beautiful.
Look strong.
God Damn
tested the flexibility.
Right.
So is this been something that we've got this all down.
That's an old school move.
They're making you do the splits.
Yeah.
Super old school.
Just lift that leg up like it wasn't shit.
Right.
Just fucking get out of here.
The fuck out it.
It's so fucking strong.
Man is a beast and in this top was ish
financially
cause the cro cop even laying under there,
it's got to hate those fucking body shots he's going for.
That
broke up.
Did a good job
for sure.
Go for the finish though again,
cause me as much as five rounds,
25 minutes.
Good pressure on the mouth.
He can't breathe for shivering when I'm out.
Yeah,
he's can't breathe for shit.
What Cro cop does mean?
He hangs on,
hangs on,
you go to posture up.
He gets the fuck out.
But Gonzaga is fucking heavy.
Follow my friend blue gala punching himself.
So that must've been a big part of his strategy.
He must have knew he would be here.
I would attack that leg,
try and get a better position.
Not Ban,
but still Gonzaga tough to shake can be tough on top.
And he also knows that he's robbing Mirko of his vitality every time he smashes
his face like that.
Yup.
Club coverages.
Ale Hall.
Plus if you're Jitsu world champion,
this is,
you know this is a walk in the park being on top position here.
Yup.
Yup,
And then you just get them out of that transition man.
The exact same path to the mountain is so slick with it.
Two men see how there's no air there.
Grape vines,
the legs.
It was like,
I don't even need to bother it.
Side control.
I go right to the mouth on this dude.
Do you see how there was no air in his transition,
which is super snows.
Oh God.
It's artistic now.
If your cro cop,
you can only get mounted so many times because he explodes to get out of it.
Yeah man,
it's a lot of gas to help to burn.
Huh?
To get a 265 pounds world champ off.
He was going to be tough and as hoists grace who would always say he's cooking
on right now.
You know,
by wearing them out like this before he sure don't sign up.
I ain't gonna lie this mound.
I hate
when guys on the bottom of Mt.
Try to punch.
Do fucker you zoom out.
Look at this God damn mouth.
Well,
the striker though,
dude,
they feel like any time they have a chance to pop your chin.
I dude knock the guy out from the mountain.
The for Japan knocked him out cold.
Well,
how about you?
Why a hall knocked a dude out from his guard.
Remember that on the show who we are.
This right Zaga trying to set up the,
was he chatting up an arm?
Warm water in an arm bar.
It's a good move.
He's a beast,
dude.
He is.
He gets us to shave his back,
look at it and he's looking for the um,
no,
it's still there looking for the Americana.
Oh,
a little blood on the Gonzaga's head.
Where's that coming from?
Boom.
Good at.
Oh Jesus.
Boom.
Great Elbow.
You know,
it's interesting that Cro cop was who?
This company,
it's interesting that you sent him a triangle that cro,
cro cop was talking about.
I didn't like the cuts because he didn't like the blood from the nurses.
What's fucking up?
It's getting them.
Boom,
boom.
Transition.
What?
Control by Gonzaga.
Look at them.
Fucking ferocious out.
Oh Man.
Got Some ferocious control
that that is exactly what cro cop was saying that he thinks needs to change
about MMA and the elbows.
Gonzaga.
Oh,
I know what you don't like,
man.
It's a bad cut,
but the only type of person that says that about grappling and elbows is a type
of person that doesn't want to get that happened to them.
As far as like him being able to do it to someone.
Of course anybody would want to be able to do it.
That was his game.
He'd be all about it.
Damn.
That'd be cool with that.
Beautiful.
Somebody before him,
fuck him up from the Mount Cro cop,
Pat Barry,
he mounted mounted and his back.
Then I just take down and they choked.
Pat Barry with one arm.
He kicked out the leg.
Did he kick out the right leg or he kicked out the left leg?
He tripped him.
He picked it up,
then tripped up the loving eyes looking at this ferocious crown and pound,
just nasty controller.
This boom.
That was the one that caught him open.
Dude,
the control console I had once he gets on top,
man,
that's nasty control of Cro.
Cop were to lose this fight.
Thank you.
Fight to get in the UFC.
That's a good question.
I mean,
they love him.
He's still a star.
He's still a legend.
He still,
you know,
like one of the most important guys in the history of MMA ever.
He's my favorite fighter of all time point.
Does the FCC in Hawaii.
We're good.
Well,
he definitely is not going to fight the Gonzaga next unless he beats him.
I mean if he kaos him right here,
we stopped talking.
If you fucking head kicks Gonzaga right here,
He's a great,
he's a great guy for the UFC to open new markets in Europe,
right?
You want him to have a UFC and the Ukraine or something.
Boom.
Open up a headline.
It would cro cop.
He's still got a few fights left him.
Well if he wants a fight again in Croatia,
even if he's not the main event,
they'll still sell them.
Mother fucker out sell out.
He's a national hero.
He's a goddamn national hero over there and like we said,
undeniable.
One of the legends of the game called soccer with the big takedown defense.
Kokab perhaps a little confidential.
He's just looking at a jab though.
Not too many left hands.
No Man.
You've got to see him open up with that kick.
Maybe even to the body.
Gonzaga gets right hand happy though.
Hmm.
Older and slower
I can talk is slowing down.
Yeah,
it's tough.
Third round man.
He put a lot of pressure on him.
Mount.
Yeah.
Held them down.
Beat on him.
But he definitely took a way less damage.
So
if he's tired right here too to fees tired,
I could see cro cop one in this.
You never know.
You never know what,
three minutes ago,
you'd never know any crazy shit to go and you've got two more rounds,
bro.
You got to remember it's five.
That's right.
I just got so excited
and he's failed last to take the attempts having worked.
I'm telling you,
man,
against the cage.
Save Your fucking energy.
Don't do it.
This is all kosher.
This is his game,
man.
He fucked me up against the cage.
Need to the body.
Buggles og while he had his back on the cro cop.
Oh.
Oh look at this second wave.
Better apps fail to the CRO.
Cops have been way better.
He's looking way better.
That was a good scramble right there.
Oh,
good.
Left hand by Cro cop.
Oh,
another one cop.
did he rocked him.
Gone.
Soccer's her shit.
Upper cut.
Yo,
come on
strong with Ganzaga.
He can't hit dude.
Oh,
we got hit again.
He should know.
He should let her know.
Don't shit.
Holy Shit.
I have stood over him like a horse dance and punchy.
Got on his knees.
Especially with the GC guy like this.
He's going to fucking chill.
He's got a pos.
Holy Shit.
What a turnaround.
Great turnaround.
What God damn turn around.
Even if this was only a three round with two minutes ago,
you could still finish them here.
Oh Shit.
Big Album.
I'm at those elbows to the car
and you got to think this is a real striker.
Throwing it from tight quarters.
He might not be able to use his body,
but guaranteed he generates way more power than the average person inaccuracy.
Oh,
those are some,
those are,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
Oh goodness.
Oh,
what a goddamn turn around.
Holy Shit.
Those are for one.
It's fuck.
Oh,
go cro cop.
He's a Pega tonight.
We got to,
Holy Shit.
What a destruction.
Dot.
That was some of the best elbows from the guard ever.
Ever,
ever,
ever.
That's what he should be.
He shouldn't be taking this down and staying in their guard.
Holy Shit.
That's when the fire comes.
How ironic is it that grappling and elbows,
it wouldn't won him the fight.
That's always complaining about how crazy we were just talking about that.
Would you put any money off?
You said,
hey cro,
cop's going to take,
he's gonna get his guard and elbow.
The Shit.
I'm just getting started with an elbow to elbow,
elbow and tight.
Local time gets hurt,
right?
They're just trying to hang on.
Watch this.
Boom.
Oh,
that was ferocious.
And then another one.
Oh Dude.
Miraco can throw some goddamn elbows.
Did he shattered my nose like that.
Oh my God.
Look at this hammer,
hammer,
boom,
boom.
What a fucking turnaround.
But we got to see some of those elbows to the guard.
Mirko Cro.
Cop has hard.
Fuck what heart?
They're good tag is still down.
His face pretty jacked up.
That's his new spark.
This new spot is in the garden.
What?
Don't fucking hard to come back from that.
What a great win for murder.
Ooh.
Look at how the sport has evolved.
Where the best place for the best striker ever to be is in the guard.
Thrown those strikes in the guard,
throwing those goddamn strikes.
That's where he needs to be.
Well,
you think about it on the ground.
He can generate power and real short areas.
It's evolved into this accurate,
smart Coleman and saying,
it comes back to Mark Coleman,
the wrestler,
right?
It all comes back to him.
Wow.
That was incredible.
Shoguns ice stumbling in the back.
He's still not right,
man.
That was incredible.
I would,
this is the only guy I would,
I would never instruct to pass the guard.
The guard
a real wow,
that's a scar you can wear for life with a big victory for cold Cro.
Cop would,
uh,
well now they're one on one.
Do they do it again?
The trilogies,
they might.
They very well might.
They very well more.
That's three in a row for Gonzaga.
Does he get cut?
What does he say?
Hold on.
What does it feel like to get the Great Suhardi?
But boy
is it going to keep was pure luck.
No translator.
I feel great.
It was,
I was stopped there.
There was five rounds and fuck the bus and we made the plan is still rounds.
Two rounds in the ring of Louis.
Just stay calm and to be believed.
Really.
We believe that they're a go forward.
You'll be doing
those elbows,
those,
Oh,
we'll get that nice uppercut to amazing.
Oh my God.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Of course.
Have you taught,
wow
for me to be calling y'all fight.
He's such a bad mother fucker.
Would it be?
Just goes on a tear on everyone who beat him.
What comes next thing I want to do is take a shower and you gotta go ahead and
call in about an hour and a half times,
puts it not playing.
Do you mind turning the week?
Maybe one or two weeks?
Yeah,
maybe one or two weeks.
I'll take a rest and train again.
Monster.
Now,
if anybody had ever told him to retire after his losses,
you know he would have missed out on this glory.
Right?
Right.
That's why he can't retire Joe.
But what do you think is the balance between a god like this who is just going
to press on and still at times like tonight be spectacularly successful?
Or a guy like Jamie Varner who says,
you know what,
I think it's over,
but a guy like cro cop,
what's left for him to do?
That's true.
What's left?
Well,
he obviously love this as much as anything in life and this moment right now is
going to be like one of the greatest moments I've ever,
ever remember.
And he overcame a dude on the serious adversity.
He overcame,
said,
look at that son.
Best ever most finishes in UFC pride,
WEC in strike force ever.
22 Vandelay right on his tail.
Anderson behind that Shogun back in the day 16 wow.
That's nuts man.
All pride guys.
That's not what a legend that guy is.
You go back to his highlight reel and pride though.
None best.
No,
no one had a better highlight reel of finishes that kick to the body on heath
herring who showed it on this podcast before,
but it was like he went halfway into his body with that round thing.
Insane man.
Do you think about the guys he's beat?
Especially in their prime.
He'd beat Josh Barnett twice.
Beat Mark Hunt Wanderlei he lost a fade or steel man.
You have to guy decision.
He lost to a,
he lost two men,
a Toro,
but Minataro had the best chin in the world at the time and Cro.
Cop hit him with everything but the kitchen sink and the head kicked him at the
end of the first round and when the,
when the round ended Nogueira thought for a second that they had stopped the
fight to stop the fight.
They're like,
no,
it's the end of the ride.
It's like okay,
cool.
Went out in the second round,
took them down and arm bar.
I think those were the golden years of MMA.
I don't think we'll ever get it back.
Why don't know about that.
Honestly,
I think everybody always feels like the time that was passed was the great time.
But I think the time we're looking at right now with the exception of a few
divisions is so much higher level than we've ever seen before.
I think it's higher level.
It's just not the same.
What's the thing?
It's too much.
I think it's too saturated.
There was also a new thing.
Anytime there's new shit,
the old shit always looks better.
Like
what's it like when it's with music?
With everything.
Like you could say,
oh I like early iron main Reich,
early Motley Crue.
I don't like the new album,
which would be 1988 that would be new.
But now 20 years later,
that new album that came out in 1988 is,
that's an old album and that's a classic now.
And it wasn't classic back then with Joe with Joe is right now we're going to
look back in 20 years at this point and say Holy Shit,
look at all these big muscles.
I don't think so.
I cause I,
cause now if you want to be a fighter,
you can do it.
There's a way to do it.
When they were fighting,
it was like what the fuck?
How the fuck did we get?
How do we make this happen?
And these are legends now you have,
so now you know,
I hate to be Shitty,
but you have some kids come off the ultimate fighter or some girls who were
three.
No.
And then on the big stage,
these guys lost their fucking,
this rod role they play,
they play these kids these days.
It's not like,
it's not like Boston,
Black Sabbath.
No.
You know what I'll say?
I'll say hi,
make slash Jane's time right now.
I guess you look at the level of experience and competition in those pride
tournaments.
It's a higher level than we've ever been at.
I think the level is way higher now.
I think back then you had three guys that could strike really good and you
remember Bj was the only guy that could box in the night and the and the
lightweight division.
Now everybody in the prelims are,
they're all good strikers now.
It's like true levels for well rounded guy like it used to be that only a couple
of guys had professional footwork,
but now anybody in the prelims,
you can't get into the UFC unless you have professional footwork now nowadays.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You can't be half assed and now everyone is also incorporating a lot of that,
what they call neo footwork that Dominick Cruz,
Tj Dillashaw.
That's the next level.
Hyper evolve.
That's next level stuff,
but I see what you're saying.
It's pride.
It's like led Zepplin and all that shit.
But you know what a see led Zeppelin outside of the plagiarism accusations that
are pretty significant.
You just put that all aside and just look at the finished product.
God Damn,
I don't think there's anybody today that can fuck with them.
They had some goddamned songs that were just so insanely good,
so insanely good.
I mean,
you heard imagine dragons,
there's different,
I mean everybody's,
we're all have know what that is.
There's,
there's different and there's equal.
You know,
there's a lot of bands that I think are on that level,
but I just,
there's like,
hold on a love.
I don't think there's a song that's ever been better.
There's different songs,
there's awesome songs that are equally awesome,
but there's none better.
That's just like one of the all time greats.
It's up there with Voodoo child.
Kendricks to me,
and going back to think of when cro cop was fighting Vandelay Mark Hunt fucking
Josh Barnett,
God Dak and find out about these guys.
He fought and then Josh Barnett and the same night,
same night,
Theo much weight.
He gave it to mark.
Oh yeah,
mark these and these are in their prime.
These are some of the best that have ever done it.
And he's beating him.
We'll say nine.
How good was Goddamn fade or back?
Cause he was down cro cop.
That was essentially a kickboxing pout when cro cop was at his very best.
He hit him too,
man.
He fucked his nose out.
Who?
Even with some hard shots and fade or kept walking him down.
Pharaoh was chasing him down the whole fight.
He kept him on the heel,
kept him on his back foot all the time.
It's tough,
man.
Kept him backing up.
Really interesting man.
That's how God damn good federal was in his prime when he was in his prime.
The game just changes.
It's like basketball.
Like you look at basketball off the,
I don't know,
you guys aren't huge.
Basketball fans really get basketball.
Like Lebron liked the games change where it's kind of like a Fufu lead now.
Well when Michael Jordan,
the bulls were there,
it was a different time.
Man.
Basketball was better reads is never going to be as good as that.
Never.
How can he say that though?
Athletes getting better all the time and getting better,
but the game's changed because it's all about offense,
so that really no one plays defense really anymore.
It's all about the dunk and stuff like that,
but no one is preventing them from like 20 years ago to they're saying the exact
same thing.
Maybe I'm old school.
Are you old school Jordan and a Prime Mirko Cro,
cop time,
Mason legends.
Over time we're going to look back at Lebron and they say the same thing.
Yeah.
Well you maybe,
maybe he might not ever win as many championships as Michael Jordan,
but already right now you got to put them in the same class as Michael Jordan.
You were ready to limit Lebron come on you.
I think in the same class and a guy like mighty mouse.
There's never been a dude like mighty mouse.
People don't appreciate it because he weighs 125 pounds.
True,
but God damn mighty mouse is good.
He's so fucking,
he's so fucking,
he's so fucking no one cares that it's hard because he's fighting little dudes
and they're all 125 pounds and people don't appreciate it just from like the
human being perspective.
Cause first of all,
they don't have to fight gravity as hard.
They can move faster.
I got to like you,
if there was a guy like you that could move like mighty mouse,
they would have sports scientists come in and try to figure out what the fuck
you're doing.
You know,
if you,
if you were doing something like unusual,
your training methods,
everyone would start doing it.
If you could move like mighty mouse,
do you a heavyweight?
Everybody would do it.
You're right.
I agree.
I uh,
Kenny Florian told me that a DC was,
was going out one night and this was in Vegas and he sees mighty mouse talk to
the bouncer.
Like,
Bro,
let me in dcs,
like my man,
this is the world champion of the UFC.
And the guy was like,
really?
Yes.
You know,
he got him in.
That's fucking mighty mouse,
man.
It's insane.
It's just those lighter weight classes you will,
a lot of people don't know.
It's unfortunate,
but if you look at it from like the technique perspective,
like I always say that if you want to emulate somebody,
he's the dude.
He does everything perfect.
If you're around the game,
you appreciate it.
If you're a casual fan,
you don't give a fuck about the little guys.
Well,
he knocked out Benevidez,
which in my opinion was unbelievably,
nobody ever did that.
Benevidez is a monster.
He's a stud and he cracked him with one punch you to heal.
You need someone that's going to buy greyhound like another.
Conor Mcgregor at one 25 th all was it.
Person knows his shit.
Although don't get me wrong,
all it has in the last nine years,
he's a fucking monster.
He's never been bigger now that he's going to fight Conor,
it's true.
It's the best thing that ever happened to all those.
Connor,
it's hard though to deal with the disrespect and all the stuff that he does to
them.
I think it to me trouble.
I think it's to me trouble.
I think you're going to get a fucking nasty Aldo man.
Oh,
you're definitely gonna get a nasty.
Although the question is,
is going to have the stamina to do that for more than one or two rounds fight.
That's true.
But Aldo,
while he hurt Mendez at the end of a,
was it the end of the first,
when the bell,
the second,
second,
yeah.
And a Mendez tagged him,
but then,
uh,
into the,
the third,
fourth and fifth rounds,
he wound up winning a decision and he wound up,
uh,
beating Mendez.
But that was probably the best anybody had looked against.
Aldo.
It was the first time anybody ever cracked all the good men dancing.
He's very good.
Listen,
I love Connor.
Connor's my man.
But Connor Mendez isn't a good fight for Conor.
Well,
it's interesting because he's such a fucking powerful wrestling,
so God damn fast and it's the one thing we haven't seen is the powerful
wrestler.
But then you look at what he does,
alumnus,
he puts dude's away with his hands.
He's fast as fuck.
Dude.
There's no one more powerful than Mendez.
He's such a stud.
Just start I favor was saying Mendez is the biggest freak in the gym and to see
all take his best and still win.
Everyone was like Jesus.
Jesus.
Well Mcgregor is even bigger than him.
He's longer big boy and he throws some nasty left hands.
Man,
I asked,
he left.
It's a lot of weight behind it and if he can get one off and if he can really
impose that,
like his psychological game is fucking strong.
He believes in him.
Psalm and Ali,
Sonny Liston strong.
I agree.
It's,
it's strong in a weird way.
Like you see no cracks in it.
He doesn't ever back off.
It doesn't ever say anything stupid.
I'm rooting for Connor.
You know,
he never does it ever say,
I'm going to beat you into a living death.
Remember that Ken shamrock and Tito Ortiz,
come on,
man.
He never falters with his shit talking game.
It's so powerful.
It makes you deny who you are,
I think.
I think it's better for the sport if Connor wins.
I don't know about all that.
I don't know about all I do.
I don't.
I think if kind of loses,
maybe it's good for the sport.
Oh I disagree.
Why I need that fucking pink elephant in the room.
But what if it's all gray elephant?
What?
It's at a wild good fight.
Okay.
Then what do you do with comment?
Let's say he loses.
What do you do with it or you rematch?
Well,
did you just hear your head lighting the rest of the division?
Think about this division right now.
You've got Frankie Edgar's about to fight.
Your rider won't match up for Connor.
Either one of those guys.
Either one cause they can wrestle their fucking ass off your Riaa favor.
It would be interesting.
Be interesting cause we really haven't seen him at one 45 in a few years.
It's true.
He might be better at one 45 you might be better with not cutting such an
extreme amount of weight.
I mean there's a reason why he's taking this fight.
Yeah,
I know.
I don't think that's a,
you know a,
an excursion into one 45 but we didn't expect that.
Nobody expect that he's in the hunt at one 35 for the title,
but he doesn't want to fight it.
There's one way of teaching.
It's very interesting,
very interesting in Connor's big enough where he can do super fights against
Pedis or oh yeah,
yeah.
Well,
and then you know,
there's a lot of guys
at one 55 that we'd love to fight him.
It was a lot of guys that entire UFC once fight Conor what he brings to the
table,
all of them want to fight him.
Well if his best matchup,
which this is fucking insane to say,
but just style wise,
all those,
the best matchup in the top five form after that,
man,
it's trouble because we're talking about grapplers what's going to be
interesting to see if he could hang with all those standing?
I mean he clipped,
Pour,
Yay.
Early in the fight.
He did hurt him,
no doubt about it,
but we didn't get to see an exchange.
You know,
one thing about Connor that the,
I feel that,
uh,
grapplers there's a really,
really good sign and I saw it firsthand that he has the mentality to get really,
really good at Jujitsu.
That,
and I'll tell you why.
Uh,
I'm teaching class one fucking day,
maybe six months ago,
maybe eight months ago.
And,
uh,
I'm looking over at the bag and the corner,
someone's punching a bag in the corner and I'm teaching class and I look over,
I'm like,
I said,
fucking Conor McGregor hitting the bag in my jam.
So I walk over and like,
hey dude,
the first time I ever met him said,
what's that?
What the fuck are you doing here?
He goes,
Oh mate,
you know,
that'll say,
mate,
Australia.
Okay,
well I can't do an Irish accent,
but I can't do any accents.
But he,
uh,
we said,
hey,
what's up?
You know,
and told them I'm a fan and all that shit.
And I said,
Hey,
I'm just teaching,
you know?
And he goes,
okay,
I'm just,
I just needed a bag to hit.
I was down the street at hotel doing UFC shit.
So I go back to class within three minutes he shows up on the mat and just says,
where are your best guys?
And I said,
okay.
So I hooked him up with my best guys and,
and he just kept wanting to go with all my best guys.
That's amazing.
Nobody dies.
No UFC guys do that.
There's a lot of hardcore grapplers and that's what they do.
And they go from gym to gym and trying to get different looks.
Guys are looking for the best competition.
Just looking for wars,
looking for different style matchups cause you're,
you're trying to have the same guy all the time.
That's not good.
There's a,
there's a 200 styles out there and you're training with three styles every day.
You're turning the two styles every day.
Four styles.
You need big giant classes where there's so many different,
there's so many in grappling.
It's endless.
You Connor's a brown belt.
Yeah.
So he showed up,
he showed up.
And you know what,
he that showed me that he has the mentality to,
he's not afraid to grapple and train and work with whoever on the ground to
improve his grappling.
That's huge.
So from that point I thought,
you know what,
that's why he's good.
I agree.
That's why,
cause he's always on her face looking.
Do we evolve fan as well?
I'm thinking,
I mean he's definitely an extraordinary human being.
I've never had a famous UFC fighter ever do that.
They,
they,
a lot of them come by and say hi and they said they stand on the cage and they
look in and a couple of train.
But when it came down to Raleigh and they didn't want to roll famous UFC
fighters,
generally I,
I understand where they're coming from.
They're famous.
They train,
they train in some where they don't,
they don't know
the guys and you know there's going to be cameras out and maybe he gets tapped
out by a blue belt and then someone goes on the Internet and go,
I just tapped out fucking dad off from the UFC guys in the UFC dental Wonka shit
that they don't want to get hurt though either because there's gyms you I've
been to where I'll go with tough guys like you know,
some black belt,
some brown belts and then they're,
they're studs in the corner waiting for me to get tired.
It's like,
Oh last round,
let's go.
And then you ended up getting hurt.
He had this weird thing that people do when they said that they're worried about
getting hurt unless they have not telling him a fight coming like next week or
two weeks.
Then you don't grab hard cause you don't want to get hurt.
But I think they don't want to get tapped.
Yeah,
I think it's both.
I think he's supposed,
I think it's ego and they don't want to get hurt,
but it is gross.
When you see dudes sitting out and waiting for you to get tired and then they
ask you to roll,
like you just sat out,
man,
you didn't even enroll.
Are you trying to cheat cheating?
You're trying to catch someone who just ran the marathon and ask him to race.
Yeah,
it's weird man.
If there's guys that,
uh,
there's guys that all they do is leg locks.
I can see a guy saying,
hey,
I don't want to get my legs hurt.
You know,
because people believe that people believe that.
you go against the guy that's going to attack your legs,
you're going to get hurt.
I believe that shit I don't believe in anymore.
But um,
I could understand that guys,
there's dudes that are led glock assassins.
I knows also certain dudes who are hurt dudes.
We know that
they don't give a fuck.
Well that's Tokyo thing.
That's the hardest thing.
They talk about that even in the gym they had a problem with him like more than
one gym.
You can only train with his brother,
but he can only really train with his brother because if it goes with anyone
else,
he just doesn't know how to turn it off.
It's fucking ripping limbs off.
She's just cries,
roll with mayhem.
He rolls mayhem and may him tapped and he released.
But he,
uh,
if there's a,
just to see that it was a video of it online.
It said a while ago.
It was in Brazil back in the day.
He got him in a heel hook.
I think he got his back.
If I remember.
I forgot.
Maybe an arm bar or forget.
Um,
it was,
it wasn't a heal hook though.
He got them in a few things.
I think it's a combination of both though.
Eddie.
Ego,
100% sure if there's a fight coming 100%.
You don't want to get hurt.
There's all this money for sure.
For sure.
But they're worried about being embarrassed.
Yeah.
I just want some guys never get caught up.
That's why I bring up Connor.
That's rare.
That's rare,
congressman man,
I'm telling you,
that dude is special man.
He wins this fight or not.
That gives me a long ways in life.
Just a dude.
He almost retired two years ago.
I know he was,
he had a friend that couldn't find anymore.
He had a friend.
Apparently he had been injured so much in fighting.
Then he was done and you know,
he was thinking like,
what am I doing?
Uh,
I think I'm done.
And he actually didn't show up for his boxing classes and he was teaching a
boxing class.
It didn't show up for like six days or something like that.
And then finally his manager calls him out two weeks,
two weeks,
two weeks.
So the manager calls him up and his manager says,
Hey,
do you want to find the UFC?
And he's like,
Oh shit.
Here we go.
And he just decided to go full on into it.
Just went crazy right along into it.
He's really into not sparring with striking is really into that like working on
technique more than very smart.
Anything Super Smart,
very answered.
Jamie Varner was saying is that area into knots when they trim does the same
thing too.
When when Metro and first told me that,
I was like,
because metro has a weird,
Mitchell is very smart,
but he's a weird dude.
He's different.
He goes,
I don't spar man.
I just kind of,
I get to the close and I bring it back.
He goes,
all you know will spark.
You can hit me but I'm not going to hit you.
Why?
He doesn't want to do it.
That's weird material and doesn't spark fuego.
It's mark and he's on a terrace,
a working well.
I think there's a lot of those tie guys do that.
That's a big thing in Moitai like John Wayne par was talking about that when he
did the podcast that they play all the time.
Dwayne Dwayne is the same way,
man.
Well Dwayne has a whole system worked out.
Wayne is a fascinating cat.
He has a whole system worked out as far as getting people comfortable with
striking and like where he takes you into it step by step.
I would love to have him explain it.
I don't know.
Actually if he'd be willing to,
maybe it's this trade secret,
the whole belt system.
He has a whole belt system.
He's very smart dude.
When it comes to striking,
I was really,
really impressed when I saw him working with Tj.
Yeah,
I was really impressed.
I was like,
wow,
like w w Dwayne Bang Ludwig.
It's on some next level shit.
We don't have to striking coaching.
The thing is with strike and it's an ego thing too,
but we see it then NFL guys and especially in college too at these big college
and the NFL guys used to hit four times a week and kill each other four times a
week and then some coaches like,
well this,
this isn't smart.
The guys aren't getting to the game.
They look like shit in the game.
So then schools like Michigan and Ohio state,
they pulled it back and then they were successful.
Then everyone followed them.
Well now we see it in the UFC where,
listen,
you don't get to the UFC without being tough.
You're tough,
man.
There's no need to do these gym battles and take it out of here.
You're not getting paid exactly what Jamie Varner was saying.
Those are his exact words.
I haven't listened to a word.
Jamie Varner says,
I love Jamie Varna.
He's,
he's a great guy,
but I haven't listened to it.
I believe you don't need to do it in the,
in the gym,
man.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
there needs to be some sort of protocol established for training and like an
Istat like a real,
like a consensus protocol when it comes to contact.
Like how much contact should you have or even what's happening out of the camp
wouldn't happen at of camp.
There's a protocol for an eight week camp.
You're gonna spar in these days.
You can do this and it's just the way it should be and it's down to a tee.
What if someone figured that out?
Would that be the way your nutritionist is figured out?
Your Diet?
Yes.
Have that for your whole system.
Everything you do,
isn't that what they do?
Some places?
Well,
team take down.
I guarantee you mark Lehman does shit like that.
Mark Layman does that and it works for Johnny Hendricks.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Right?
Well he knows Johnny Hendricks,
Jonny very well.
Yeah.
I'm trying to know what that means.
Take his
finger and somebody's,
Hey Brendan.
All it take is figuring out,
okay,
uh,
there's,
what,
where are you going to put your wrestling during the week?
Where are you gonna pick your striking?
Everyone does that.
She's talking about,
but where is it overtraining?
When should you spar?
Yeah.
That include that too.
Sparring Day.
Wrestled this day.
I'm with you.
But to where it's the most efficient.
Yeah.
Now I'm smart.
I was sparring when I get ready for trash round.
I was sparring fucking hard twice a week at black house.
Fucking hard man.
You know what I'm saying?
You think that's a bad idea?
Bad idea.
And you said this also about your Ben Rothwell fight sparring with Carlin.
I got knocked out before the Ben Rothwell fight by Carlin left Hook and how far
out?
Uh,
before I fought Nogueira Carwyn rocked me so bad.
Two weeks before ou in front of everyone.
And then we're on the ground.
Let me tell this story.
I'm getting ready.
We,
we do an open gym in Denver.
Hey,
come check out local fucking Guy Brendan Schaub in Denver Getting Ready to
fight.
No.
Garren Brazil like an asshole.
We invite family.
Everyone's like rocky too.
Yes.
I haven't seen Shane and he's helped me.
Nothing.
This camp.
Shane's on a boat an hour away.
My coach goes,
Bro,
you're supposed to be here showing us.
Ah Shit.
It's Saturday.
Who?
Gay Man?
He's Brendan's banking.
Any there's fucking,
everyone here goes uh,
gimme a second hour fucking shade.
Smells like sunscreen.
Sun Burnt to stall.
Shitty because who has gloves?
Gets gloves on I think at like cutoff Jean shorts and a fucking van Halen
shirts.
Just some daisy dukes and hail.
This literally literally tells us,
tells his son,
he's like,
just wait over there.
I'm like,
I'm going to fucking destroy this.
Heck,
what the fuck you doing Shane?
He's like,
you ready?
Cracks next assigned like,
yeah,
just fucking jumped out at me like a fucking great white shark.
Left Hook.
Boom.
I'm like,
whoa.
It reminds you.
All my family and friends were like,
oh my God,
she's gonna kill shot.
Shane's on top ground and pounding.
I dropped you off.
He drives me.
I come to,
I go,
what the fuck are you doing?
He goes,
sorry bro.
Here,
get up,
get up and then take me down.
I'm like,
no,
this isn't doe Wu.
I'm like,
stop.
Stop.
My told my coach,
I'm like,
I'm fucking rocked man.
And then I find Nogueira.
Wow.
And he knew that you were about to have a fight.
That shit.
Super old school man.
Shit,
shame.
No one made me more tougher than chain.
No one gave me more head trauma then champion Jesus Christ.
Love that.
So the Rothwell fight,
how far out was it again?
Two weeks.
Cause then that's really when I,
when I was in Denver that last,
the two weeks out was when we went balls to the wall where it was me,
Shane,
only three rounds and it was weird trying to knock each other out and you know
what we do?
The coach would go 30 seconds,
the entire gym,
which shut the fuck down and watch me and Shank is 30 seconds,
minute technique out the window.
Plant your feet and punched her in the face.
Oh my God.
That's what I would do and I used to bank on it.
People are like,
Oh,
you're the best shot.
That was so cool.
I'm like,
yeah,
thanks man.
Why used to bank on that?
That was like my things like,
yeah,
shop,
go toe to toe with Darwin.
Man is so cool.
Bad idea,
man.
And I'd go in the bathroom,
throw up,
I'd get in my car.
I went know how to drive home.
Oh my God.
Jamie tells me the same thing.
Call me.
That was amazing,
brother.
I'm fucked up.
True story,
man.
Some Cheech and Chong.
I know,
Dude.
It's like,
dude,
where's my car?
Oh my gosh,
crazy.
So crazy.
When I think back on it now,
I'd be like,
no,
like get the fuck out.
Or like when I was getting ready for camp at Black House,
they do this thing where they do rounds and you have to leave your foot in.
They put three cones out,
you have to leave your foot in the cone and then spar guys just to work on,
you know,
staying in the pocket moving and I was just getting started man.
And they were doing like 12 rounds.
I did,
I did like six.
Did you rotate guys are just,
yeah,
you'd rotate guys.
Oh my.
And I did like six and then I was like,
dude,
I'm taking some shots here and this is an older,
you know,
big brown.
And I was like I'm good man.
I'm like I wish I was that smart when I was young.
Different people have different systems as far as teaching people how to strike
and moving in like certain positions every time.
Time and time again when you watch like the really high level kickboxers from
Holland,
they all have like a very systematic approach.
Like I'd love to get you to sit down with a or to train rather with rob came in,
rob came in was a real interesting guy when it comes to that stuff.
He's got a system and he teaches a system of it a lot.
Like a lot of people teach a Jujitsu system now is complex is like your system
because your system is just infinite number of moves and positions,
but,
and had like a deep,
deep knowledge of that Dutch style kickboxing.
So he's a heavyweight and he's trained.
He's a bitch.
He's a big fella.
Um,
I don't know if he's technically he's over 205 pounds.
I mean,
he's a bigot.
He's a big fella,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
Rob came and if you go back and watch the highlight reel ever.
Yeah,
he was tremendous.
His technique was spectacular in Santa Monica right here.
Now I think he's staying in Topanga and he's here now.
He's in town.
Um,
what a great guy too.
Just a sweetheart of a guy.
But he's a,
he's interesting because he like,
he was responsible for a lot of,
uh,
Brandon Vera's early success.
That's right.
That's why I know the name.
Yeah.
He was working with Brendan Vera early in his career and uh,
whether or not that's why Brendan was so successful.
It's up to debate,
you know,
but he was doing really well back then when he was with Cayman.
Um,
I mean that's when he beat prank me or it's when he beat,
he beat a lot of guys got silver.
Silver heavyweight story was sober.
Was that who it was?
Did it get to you and him?
Can you teach them?
That's it's the w who did he head kick?
Kao He had cacao.
Justin Eilers.
Justin.
Yeah,
Justin,
Heather's.
And then he uh,
need Frank Mir.
Remember that's when it's right for them.
And then he got on the mic.
It was like going to be the first five ever heavyweight light heavyweight.
Yeah.
He looked good back then.
He was an ass look good.
And that's those,
the rob came in days d related or not related,
I don't know.
And then there was,
but there was also,
when
you talk about him,
you've got to talk about,
he had a contract dispute,
so he's out for a long time.
There was a contract dispute with the UFC came back.
A lot of pressure on him didn't perform that well when it came back.
That taking that downtime off contract disputes to that's talking fuck with your
head man.
I think he's still fighting in one FC.
Yeah,
he is.
He's a heavyweight heavyweight again.
Yeah.
He said,
fuck this diet.
Yeah.
Well especially one FC.
I don't know what sort of Mexican synced up with supplements they,
uh,
they test for.
Yeah.
I don't either.
Do they have the full menu of Mexicans,
Mexican supplements?
That's trouble fighting a brand and very on anything.
Well,
a lot of these guys,
they say like,
you know,
let them take it.
Why not,
you know,
have an organization where they do take it.
Let's see what happens.
You know,
if you've got international fighters at fight over there to say,
Hey,
this is the pride of Asia,
this is how it goes.
We're not,
we're not going to test it for steroids.
We don't have to over here.
There's one FC test.
I don't know.
I have no idea,
frankly,
the big dog over.
Yeah,
right.
He's running it.
Yeah,
he's running it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's ask,
does one FC test for starts?
What do you,
what do you think I'm going to say?
No,
I say no to fuck.
he's not mean anything outside of the United States.
I,
I'm always sketchy about men.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
It doesn't want to just give a fuck.
It's
due to
steroid use in American football.
Why is it thing to go too many?
The meds?
Yeah.
Is that it?
You got to get on Twitter for that.
You think so?
You think you got to just ask people someone texts rich Franklin,
does he really going to tell Scott?
I know on Twitter,
do they test your steroids at one?
Is it the number one?
Is it one number one FC or zero n?
E.
F says,
try this.
Yeah.
No one FC champion versus champion been Astrin bitches in beauty,
so doesn't say,
I dunno.
Oh,
drug tests were clean.
Okay.
That means they have a drug test,
one of see it,
but pride used to say that now in dare you probably like,
no,
we're good bots upset.
Yeah,
we're good.
Everybody's fine there.
That is an art.
George Oliveira is it?
Yeah.
He fought for them for a while.
For one I've seen.
Okay.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you mean?
Which George Oliveira you talking about from legends?
I think it's him,
isn't it?
First of all?
Well,
it's his drug tests were clean stain that George Valera tested positive for
steroids.
How dare that.
Let's check.
Like I said,
ma'am,
anything outside the United States makes me skeptical.
Hippo.
Skeptical Hippo.
Whether you're seen that meme,
it's a skeptical with just sketchy eyes.
No skeptical hippo.
Yeah.
It's a funny meme.
Have you seen it?
Oh,
this is a different God.
That's the George Oliveira that tested positive in the Ryan laflair fight.
That's a different,
that's the guy who fought Ryan Laflair in the UFC rates recently,
right?
I'm not,
he didn't fight.
Ryan will flare.
He fought in the Rhino for undercard.
Excuse me.
We're flying a little flair.
Fought a Damien Maia.
Oh,
Damien Maia.
Maia look great.
Right?
[inaudible] tough.
This is our buddy.
That's our buddy.
Allavara
skeptical.
Hippo is skeptical.
There it is.
So Nice.
That's my face when you ask if they do steroids.
George Oliver.
That's all I know.
That guy.
I've trained with that guy.
Right.
So there's more that obviously there's more than one.
George Oliveira wait,
he's not your friend?
No,
that guy is,
that guy is our friend.
He trains,
he trains.
Yeah.
From legend.
Right.
Legends MMA was,
um,
back in the day.
It was a fun place,
man.
I went there,
I bought a tee shirt.
I came to La with a buddy and I at the time wasn't fine.
I went to legends just because Randy couture on,
I bought a tee shirt,
like a fan boy ward around.
Awesome.
Hey,
let's watch that fight.
If we can,
let's see if we can watch that.
Um,
Quinta.
Yeah,
the ally quantified or um,
that was the one that we wanted to watch.
And the other one that we wanted to watch was the,
uh,
the Kao,
the Gustafson Anthony Johnson red button.
We'll watch that first.
Go Take a pee young man.
Yes sir.
Hey,
uh,
if we have time,
I would,
I would love your opinion on Kathy lungs.
Highlight rail.
Oh,
she's dope.
Do Right.
I've seen her fight before.
She was one of those American kickboxers from back in the day.
Right.
She moved.
Yeah.
Well,
very well.
Yeah.
She,
uh,
she was bad ass dude.
She was bad ass.
She wants to fight.
Does she?
Yeah.
She's trying to get a fight right now.
Catholic.
She's just for the 51 and she's in great shifty one.
She's in great shape.
I see her twice a week and my gym,
she's in great shape.
Wow.
Yeah.
She's trying to get a fight,
but that's amazing.
51 Invictus should look into her.
Kathy,
Kathy Law and can still strike.
She's still down ass and her and she's got a decent defensive Jujitsu.
She can,
she actually fought MMA like two,
three years ago and while she really,
yeah,
she fought in,
Ooh.
What show is that?
That's up on youtube too.
Um,
she won.
She was 49 and she won.
Wow.
That's amazing.
She really wants to fight.
She is vicious.
Really?
Yeah.
She's 51 and she wants to fight like now.
This is hard.
It's like,
I guess promoters are worried about her age.
Yeah.
It's hard to sell that man.
It's hard to sell that,
but when you look at her highlight reel dude,
you're like,
oh shit,
she could probably pull it off.
I think
well today are more worried about people getting hurt that are older than ever
before,
you know?
Yeah.
Well LIGO would,
cro cop just did shit.
How old is Cro cop?
40,
40 and our hard 40,
uh,
40,
you know of a who has been fighting top level competition for a long time,
you know,
in and out of the gym.
I don't think it's on,
um,
they don't have it on Cypass goddammit too.
So he,
I don't know.
Is it a,
is it a Fox fight?
Yeah,
it is a fun site.
Maybe it doesn't get on fight pass.
Cause that makes sense.
Yeah.
It doesn't appear to be in the library and listen,
I'm retarded.
Which is possible.
You can't find it.
I'm Anthony Johnson.
You should be able to not know.
That's what I'm looking for.
I'm not bad.
That be sharp graphic down there.
We'd Lavar Johnson.
Nice.
Pretty Young.
Anaconda.
Pulpa let's try,
um,
let's see if we can find the outlier quantified here.
Yeah,
I think if it's not,
I think I have it on direct TV.
I think I saved those here.
Let's see.
I Quinta versus Ross Pearson.
That's a good fight.
All right.
Quinn.
Hmm.
Doesn't seem to be on here either.
I couldn't tell him.
Ask Dow.
Come on bitch.
Uh,
it doesn't look the that's on there man.
I mean,
can you get the uh,
God,
then you get into some weird shit.
I was going to say,
you can get the replay.
There it is there.
It's not on fight.
Pass somewhere else.
Okay,
cool.
Go full screen on that shit son.
Don't be scared.
Here it is.
What does it on?
This is something illegal.
We legally streaming right now.
Maybe.
Dammit.
Jamie,
you're going to get us in trouble.
We're going to watch this.
A fight to see how clearly you're sure we could find just the highlight
[inaudible] video two.
Is it choppy?
I can find that.
Sure.
We can find the,
yeah,
the highlight.
Did you use that new component and have a chance to figure it?
Oh,
okay.
Let's just see it for a second.
Yeah.
You know what it does to be too choppy to be able to distinguish whether or not
I was a headbutt.
Sure you can get a slut.
How come?
It's okay when you're on a short screen like that.
It's not working.
Oh really?
I was trying to catch up.
So it's like a video card thing.
Yeah.
Wow.
And that's what that little components for you make it better.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh this is,
so this is post k o w we're going to have to take it to the moment he gets hurt.
There's a fight.
I haven't seen him.
I was on a plane when this really?
Yeah.
You got to take ticket way back before that Jamie.
Way Back,
like right about there,
like right about where the cursor was.
Need to go further back because he heard him and then he'd stalked him down for
a while.
Here it is.
Look to the uses of this means a fight is already,
oh,
that's the pope to the eye.
Okay,
so this is the start up after the poke the eye.
Here we go.
Boom.
That's it.
That's what did it.
Yeah.
It's a right as well,
man.
It's a Ha.
What does he need to see?
The slow motion man?
Yup.
I think Anthony was going to win this fight anyways,
whether that headbutt happened up,
but in this certain case,
the headbutts what?
Fucking destroyed Alexander's.
Okay,
so tell me what you think him versus John John's.
What happens?
John's reaches too much.
John.
We'll take them down and the inside leg trip where I'm out,
elbows from the guard might submit them or TKM I think it goes three rounds.
Wow.
Strong words.
And I'm a,
and I'm a fan of Anthony.
I like Anthony.
He's a fucking nightmare.
Boom,
boom.
It's interesting,
but every fight John,
like here's the guy,
here's the guy who's going to beat him very is wrong.
Well how long can rumble do this?
Like how long can he fight like this?
Like this is extreme pace.
He's putting on Augusta sentence like he's gambling and he's gonna Finish
Gustafson,
you know?
I mean,
he's going full out.
I'm,
and he's got them hurt real bad and it worked here.
Yeah.
If a guy can recover,
get to guard or something.
If a guy can't keep from getting hit will do,
but Jesus Christ or something nasty man.
If a guy can keep from getting tagged by him and can take him into the third,
fourth and fifth rounds,
what does that look like?
Well,
against Phil Davis Look Pretty fucking scary.
He looks scary in the second and he looks scary and the third,
but there was Phil Davis who doesn't present as many striking dangers as Jon
Jones.
You gotta remember Jon Jones dismantled [inaudible] feet towards very similar to
Anthony Johnson when with John fought him.
He was explosive.
Is Fuck powerful.
Remember that?
Yeah.
You gotta come that arm bar,
but he ended up submitting but Vittorio considerably smaller.
Not at the time.
Think About v toward roid it the fuck to the gills.
Yeah.
I mean he weighed two a five but he's a different two oh five in this fucking
guy,
man.
Oh Lord.
Let me see that again.
Say that again.
That was,
that was interesting.
Notice headlands,
that lands,
I got to see it from the other angle me to look like with a headbutt.
It didn't.
No.
Okay.
Let's see it again.
Here we go.
We're going to see it right here.
Watch this.
Oh Dude,
that's a right hand.
Let me see one more time.
One more time.
See,
that's what I'm saying.
It seems so that angle's rough.
Let me say it one more time and then he seemed all right after that he was
moving around and Dan is pretty fucked up.
I felt so bad for you.
We go one more time.
One more time is the kick.
Bam.
Dude.
I think the head didn't hit.
I think they are crazy.
It's hard to do a better angle because that right hand,
not this one.
This one.
It looks like it landed.
Hits the shoulder to shoulder.
It doesn't man.
That ain't cool.
It does.
It looks like Tony more time.
If you can't turn the other view going back to the same spot caught back up.
He got headbutted.
That would be check it out again.
You'd be able to see the impact was no think the head goes to the left and the
right hand lands.
You might've bumped heads at the same time.
That was just awesome.
It would be us as a bad angle.
See that there was no,
you would see the impact.
The other you can tell though when we get this approved or film
could have hit him,
could have hit him on the right eyebrow.
Can't you type it on youtube or something for me cause they give you different
angles.
Here it is.
One more time.
Boom.
He could be handling it that hard to do that.
Could
you take it landed that hard?
Look how fucking Hardee's throwing it.
He's throwing his whole body into it.
His back comes off bad.
The other one,
it does fail it one more time.
Let's say it one more time from that other angle.
I'm telling you if we can just pull some bullshit,
he get another angle on youtube.
One more time that worry about it.
It's like some kid in the crowd.
He didn't throw this right hand hard.
It's crazy.
Watch this right here.
Doesn't look hard.
Wham.
Are you kidding me right there.
It doesn't.
Oh you're so crazy.
He throws everything into that punch right here.
It looks like.
What's his face?
See it again.
Pack it up,
Ryan,
through his it up again on the clavicle,
dude,
Bro.
Sis,
I'm telling you,
there's one more thing on youtube on the other side.
This right hand,
the idea that he's not throwing that hard is so crazy.
I think it landed right here.
It didn't land in the face and hits his face and then it hits the clouds looking
at hit his face right here.
It does.
This right here.
It doesn't.
The head hit dude,
that hit his fucking chasely.
It hit his fucking chicken then.
Oh,
come on back it up again.
Look at his,
his fucking face.
It hits his cheek and then it goes into his car.
Donald did it hits his face first.
Right here you're blind.
You need to go to a doctor.
Boom.
That punch hits his face.
Punch Punch 100 periods is hear me.
Do you see when you get up in the morning?
100% no,
Jamie,
there's an angle from the other side.
One more time.
No,
no.
This isn't the evidence.
This is what the evidence shows.
It's not just a video.
No big deal.
On the other side.
One more time.
He'll go chin.
Look,
watch this.
Now watch this.
Next one.
It hit Kalir.
It's fucking his hair
before it hits anything from a headbutt.
The Punch lands on the fucking cheek.
That's what you were arguing against.
You were saying it hits his clavicle.
It definitely wasn't his clavicle that punches and then glances off and then
hits him on the gentlemen.
Here's the other view.
What are you talking about?
This view?
You can't see the punch land.
You can see the head,
but just
watch it looks like he hit him in the head with a Headbutt,
right?
What's it slowly,
slow,
slow look.
Bright hand writing and hit the Chin first clearly right and hits the cheek is
100% but hits the tank and
definitely headbutted him afterwards.
But the rights,
he could hit him first.
I've got to agree with you on that.
I'll give you that.
There is a head but at 100% but look,
there's a handbook but it is a headbutt for sure,
but here at boom,
right hand first.
Do it one more time.
Watch this to right.
Where does it go?
Dude?
Do what you just did.
Watch one more time.
Look that head butt though son.
But the right hand came before it.
I agree.
Backing up to where you're both,
there was a headbutt.
Okay,
go ahead.
Dot.
No,
no,
no.
It's before that.
Here it goes.
Watch.
This will be the right hand.
See,
but it's clear as day pull and that's head.
But no,
he hit him in the fucking cheek.
No.
Do you see from the overhead that punch lands on his cheek?
It lands on his cheek and jaw oath.
It's called Bam on the face and then headbutt Bam.
Right there.
100% headbutt hundred percent punch lands for agree.
Both.
Both of them are damaging.
Fucked him up.
So from that thing with the one that fight,
either way,
I'm not taking anything away from Johnson from that angle,
100% they collide heads.
So now we know,
but also 100% that punch lands first.
You should see it right there dude.
And Doom.
Yup.
Beat him.
Fair and square.
Crazy powerful Anthony.
But I don't think it matters the punch lands first.
I mean there was a headbutt.
It definitely wasn't that bad,
but he got tagged by that right hand on the face first,
which was lob comes right.
Which one wobbled him more is a good question.
Who the only one can answer is him really and I bet even he can I believe so out
of it.
He can't,
yeah.
What do you do in a situation like that?
If you have the guidelines,
a punch and then the head but lands in the Headbutt con clearly the guy lands a
punching gets hurt but the headbutts stiffens him up and he goes out part of the
game.
It is part of the game but what do you say that happens but the method of Kao
was kind of Headbutt Right.
We should bring back headbutts.
It would have to be like how much time has passed between them because like say
if you tagged guy with a right hand and he was wobbly as fuck and he was backing
up in a few seconds go by and then he throws a right hand and misses and you
collide heads and he goes unconscious.
True.
Then what happened?
Then what do you do?
Well then you need a rematch.
I think that one was like,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like you can't ask for a rematch.
The fight like that,
it killed that magnitude.
They would have to be some sort of a huge event.
See,
I wanted to see Gus fin and DC fight next.
That's a good fight.
That's a great fight.
I wish they were doing that instead of separating them.
Well,
gossips in versus baders an interesting fight too,
man would bait or did to open st Prue.
I thought it was really interesting,
but OVN.
St Prue is not new either.
Wrestler that DC is DC who's wrestler,
especially when you're dealing with a guy who was his size cloud,
not a long,
tall guy like Jon Jones who is so awkward and strong,
but a guy more his size.
I fixed stocky guy like Beta Beta.
Beta won't take DC down proof.
Oh yeah.
He's fighting soon too.
When is that?
He's fine.
My boy Pat Cummings
is a fucking nightmare.
Yeah,
he's a great guy,
man.
He awesome.
Awesome,
great guy.
Sweet man.
I hate to say super athletic,
but God dammit,
he pushed the University of Tennessee national,
not professional,
professional,
but I'm at a elite,
elite athlete,
Division One athlete.
I need received Tennessee.
He loves it and twisters,
man lots.
He loves it.
He already has a calf crank from the truck.
He already has a Jason von flue choke.
Remember that?
Yeah,
he got that dude in a von flue,
Joe.
He rushing cat.
There's a lot of dudes you don't even know that position
up at Pat Cummings.
I'm telling you is a fucking monster.
He's a monster.
Pat will win that fight,
that fucking left hook that knocked shogun out.
Now,
man,
sidestep a specimen.
I know,
man.
I,
and I've trained a little,
very well on the ground.
Super,
very good grappler.
He loves playing London.
Uh,
he,
he loves playing also known as Sean Williams.
God,
he loves going there.
Coming back.
Pat Cummings is one of those guys.
He's like Rashad Evans.
It's fucking impossible.
Submit man.
He trains with VRE doom all the time and me all the time and gets in the worst
positions ever.
He's a tough dude too,
man.
It's cutting weight down to a tee.
Yeah,
and has insane endurance and work ethic.
Good luck with that.
His work ethic and the such,
such good bytes,
but makes baby Eddie Bravo up that chat.
Open shows power.
It was nasty.
The money on it.
Let's do it.
How much you want put your thousand dollars
$80,000
20 bucks for fun.
$20
give you a $20 chipolte lay.
No,
it's how about,
how about a dinner?
How about it did you take the three of us out to dinner?
The loser buys dinner,
whereas at the good place,
wherever we want,
thousand dollars
we'll go get a steak somewhere.
Yeah,
Morton's wherever.
Damn.
You're willing to gamble on there.
Oh,
Vince wins anyways and I still pay for it.
How about
that
thousand bucks?
Fucking a thousand right here.
Do you really want to do a thousand or you want to do dinner?
What's going to happen?
Let's play a thousand fucking ratable dude.
Oh Vince,
so bolts.
You listen to me.
I'm betting Brendan,
1000 it's on you that you really want to get involved in this.
You've got to decide right now before we touch hands.
It was my idea.
I'm calling your bluff.
Thousand dollars
a
thousand dollars I swear to God it was my idea,
but it was a bluff.
It's not a bluff.
We both have our size.
You kept back out,
back out.
Don't back out.
I'll do a thousand end dinner.
Oh my God.
Pat,
you've got to train your ass off.
When is that fight?
Goddammit.
I'm two weeks.
It's on the Machida card.
Oh my goodness.
All right.
I wanted cash.
No bills.
No fucking check,
man.
Oh,
right off.
Don't bring me a 10th planning check
operation that I get it.
I'll give you $1,500 in private lesson.
You got a free gym membership.
Yeah.
I actually charged 15 in an hour.
Try 16 now.
I'll give you a break all you owe me a hundred bucks,
dude.
I'm a little nervous now.
That really,
that really escalating and say definitely that's a lot of rotting.
Thousand Bucks is real cash.
That's real cash.
That's going to fuck him up.
Trust me.
He's not.
You know what's going to happen.
Pat comes going to break him in the second round.
You can see what's going to happen.
This is what's going to happen.
Pat,
listen,
look me in the eye.
I'm just going to get twisted twist or he's going to get twisted.
Your fun.
I bet my entire bank account,
he doesn't get submitted.
Okay.
What kind of odds on the twist or would you give?
What are odd?
Okay,
here's the odds on the twister.
If he gets him in the twister,
you got to bet you bet a hundred and if he gets him into twist or he has to give
you 10,000 okay,
that's
the right od for sure.
That's about right.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
He's good dude.
That's not when it's training with you full time.
No K two wigs.
Just have it all.
He said that to win.
It's a very good bad,
it's an interesting bad,
it's an interesting fight.
You got to look at the fact that he knocked out shogun with one fucking punch
like that and say this kid is a stud and he's getting better and he's fast and
he's striking his fucking for sure dangerous and powerful,
but the odds of him winning bike twister when only one person,
everyone by twister ever in the history of the fucking UFC.
And that's the Korean Zombie one goddamn twister of all time.
The ads that he wins by a twister,
I say a hundred to 10,000 they want you on.
I mean sure.
That's very,
very reasonable.
That's even reasonable.
I think God's or a reasonable one in a million.
It probably more than low.
So you are doing is stealing $100 from Eddie Bravo.
Okay.
I'm already stealing a thousand telling you,
let's do it.
Let's have another bed.
$100 bet.
If he gets him into twister,
you'll owe me 2000 uh,
no.
Uh,
10,000
but if he doesn't,
if he doesn't,
what do I get?
100.
A hundred bucks either stealing a hundred.
That's gifts,
Tim.
Yes,
that's right.
I'll fucking Kentucky and I will be doing twisters.
I'll look.
What if Pat Summitt.
Tim,
what if Pat Summitt.
Tim doesn't matter.
New Jersey.
It's in New Jersey and two weeks.
Shit,
I'm in town.
Is it the 25th April 25th whatever city you're in that Hickson Hickson.
Gracie is having a seminar on the 25th so it's the 25th what's that?
Montreal.
That's that one is the 25th yeah.
Oh,
this is the Fox card.
Here's the fire announcing it,
right?
Yeah,
I'm announcing that one.
Oh,
I'm announcing the Montreal card to Demetrius.
It's a paper be mouse Johnson here.
Goshi card card took ahead.
Huh?
Rampage Lewis and or getting pulled out of the car rather is a is a bad one that
was going to happen.
Didn't like that man.
I thought that they could work that shit out.
I thought that,
I mean I think that if there is some sort of a a break in the contract enough to
where he can sign with the UFC,
I felt like they would have already worked it out.
You would think his lawyer or you think the UFC lawyers who are the best in the
business,
but like,
dude,
don't promote them yet.
We don't know.
Let's figure this logistics out and then do it.
Yeah,
it was too rushed.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't know,
man.
Maybe they thought that they would be able to get it in under the wire before I
risk it.
I don't know.
Risk what you've already established.
The rap page doesn't want to be in Bella tour,
so whether he didn't know,
not,
but now not really because now the court saying what money would you still got
to fight for Bella Toy,
but then it's a little board is,
you know the court granted an injunction I believe.
I believe they kept him for fighting for the UFC,
but they didn't say that he has to fight for Bela Tarr.
They recognized an argument and it has to be worked out now,
so they just said,
you can't fight for the UC at this.
Exactly.
At this point,
the granted an injunction.
I think that's exactly how it works.
If I had to bet,
I would probably using the wrong terminology,
but I'm pretty sure that's exactly how it works.
So rampage can't fight for the UFC.
So the car takes a big hit and wasn't there another fight in the car to the got
pulled.
What was the other fight that got pulled?
Another big one,
right.
Was it Royce was to be on that,
but they took him off to put them.
Roy.
He's now fighting for the title title,
but I thought it was supposed to be there.
My crazy.
Well that's a great place for him to fight.
He lives there.
That's where it was supposed to be.
And they took him off that and put them on that Vegas card.
Well that Vegas card is a monster man.
And when they have those title fights in Vegas,
it's worth a shit load of Cheddar.
The fuck.
Yeah.
Shit load of Shit.
A lot of money.
And those Vegas cards,
man,
you know,
and because people like to go there,
man,
they will.
They will.
The Vegas loves it.
People like to do it.
It's a different animal when it's in Vegas.
And the money that it generates for the casino is insane and comparison to the
money that it generates for some random arena somewhere.
If you put it on it,
some random arena in Montreal,
I mean it's great for the economy of Montreal,
but the amount of money that gets spent in Vegas is off the goddamn charts.
Everyone,
they'll fight jam.
Blake is making a big comeback or they making a come back.
Well,
they definitely took a big hit.
I think it's more of a normalization.
The economy goes down,
gambling goes down.
There's no way around it.
People don't have the money.
I think the hotels are taking a huge hit.
The shit was crazy as hotels,
they're not doing well.
We were in a car once and we asked the driver,
uh,
his cab driver,
like how much different is Vegas right now?
And he goes,
it's 50% down,
50% down.
You said 50% down and calls 50 beach sent down in business.
Like they're all aware of it.
I know.
I know that city center,
the engineer fucked up building it and it's not safe structurally and they have
to rip it down.
Why?
It's no way.
This might be breaking news,
big ground stone ground breaking.
I'm pretty sure I read gigantic.
Pretty sure I read that on a phone call from a kid.
Let's get home.
God.
Swear.
Swear though.
I'm almost positive.
Wow.
Something structurally is fucked up and they have to tear it down.
It's like tons of tons of money.
Let's get young Jamie,
to pull up some articles on this bullshit.
To me that sounds insane.
If that's the case,
what a huge hit.
Someone that's terrifying.
Someone really powerful in Vegas.
Told me back when I was working with the UFC,
he said it's like it used to be that the casinos or packed and then now it's
like someone took a giant vacuum and just vacuumed all the people out of the
casino.
Yeah,
that's what it looks.
I'm not a Vegas guy.
Never.
You know,
it's real weird when you go off the grid,
when you get out of the Strip and you go to them funky casinos that are out in
the middle of nowhere pressure.
Whoa.
There's a lot of casinos in Vegas,
so you don't ever think about,
there's a lot of like weird fucking casinos all over the spot.
That's for the true grit gamblers guys that they just want to gamble,
that don't want to be on the strip.
They just want a place where they could go.
Well,
you just see a different tone of human being.
It's almost a different creature.
Dude.
Colons,
gall and shape don't give a fuck last night I countries people.
That's why he's got to keep that mode.
That makes it keep that gut.
Do you ever go to commerce casino?
That place is packed.
That was our last night.
There was some fights.
That was Bama fights.
Eddie Jackson.
Oh really?
One.
He looked like chuck with Dell and it's Prime Eddie Jackson just destroy this
guy.
But uh,
the place was packed and it was 98% Asian.
They love the gamble.
Oh yeah.
The place was packed.
It was.
That's different though cause that's not Vegas.
These are these local casinos is all they got.
It's like this or drive four hours to Vegas.
True.
If you're a card gambler,
you can gamble right here.
If you're a poker guy,
there's plenty of gambling in la.
Like Ari Shaffir before he made it as a comic was making more money gambling on
poker.
He was on eighth no,
usually playing in tournaments.
Oh Wow.
He was going to fucking really good.
He's very good.
Ari,
smartest shit dude.
So he would go to these poker tournaments and when he made 35 grand one year
just playing poker and he wasn't making much money.
As a comic who's struggling?
It's crazy.
You can make some money and you can,
you can get action.
That's the big thing I heard.
Online's the way to do it though.
Could you sit at home in your fucking underwear out?
Illegal in America anymore.
It's different.
Like I think you have to go to places like Nevada.
You can gamble online,
but you can gamble.
You can play poker online against people from Nevada.
I was like,
all those pro poker players,
a lot of them moved out of country.
A lot of them moved to Menai Monaco.
Monaco.
How'd you say that?
Monica Monaco.
They moved to Monaco.
They moved to all these countries where it's legal.
They,
some of them moved to China and they play in that Chinese place.
Oh,
huge.
What's that?
That area of Macau.
Macau.
Yeah.
Apparently her Macau is going off crazy.
They say it's Vegas Times 10 that's what I've heard.
Just a Mad Asian gangs hurting Dubai's the same way.
Really not
gambling.
No gap.
As far as crazy.
It's Islamic,
right?
We run out of time.
How dare you?
We're having a hard time jumping on the scamming and good the time.
Give us five minutes.
What's that?
Yeah,
let's go part two.
You want you guys got something to do?
No,
let's do another hour.
It's chill.
Shower.
All right.
Kill this and we'll come back.